some tour dates to announce
if you want to come see The Return of
the Rat tour
we'll be in Louisville Kentucky January
25th and 26th Indianapolis Indiana
January 27th and 28th Shreveport
Louisiana February 1 and 2. Baton Rouge
Louisiana February 3 through 5.
Corpus Christi Texas March 24
Houston Houston sorry Texas March 25th
uh Phoenix Arizona April 26th through
29th New York City at the Beacon Theater
May 13th in Austin Texas June 1st
through 3rd
um some of those dates are getting sold
out some of those dates we will be
adding new shows to I know specifically
Austin uh Phoenix and possibly uh
Houston you can get tickets at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r make sure to access tickets
through there to get accurately priced
ticketing uh thank you guys so much if
you do come out to a show and you want
to leave something for us
a gift or an item or something you can
always leave it with the merch people at
the merch table uh just so you know that
uh thank you guys so much for all your
love and support
um I'm excited to uh to come and see you
you know it's hunting season it's
hunting people are out there
setting traps snares
put a Taffy some people put a damn Taffy
out there
and they'll catch a pigeon on that [ __ ]
people do all kind of thing if you like
to hunt
then check out the hitter hunting club
collection new merch now available at
Theo vonstore.com
we've got hoodies in Orange and maroon
we got a raccoon on one of them because
you know my brother's out there killing
raccoons out there out in um
Southern Utah
he's out there uh
we're just really getting those little
damn criminals they are we got camo hats
traditional and orange we got it all
Elmer fudge yourself up Elmer fud your
cousin man fud your cousin a bunch of
cousin futters
get that hitter and more at
theovanstore.com today's guest is an
astrophysicist he's an author he has a
new book called Starry Messenger
Cosmic perspectives on civilization
we're going to chat a little bit about
it
and he's just that you know he's that
Galactic bad boy he's that um
you know he's that uh outer space uh Joe
Montana you know he's going deep with
the facts baby you know what he is
um he's science
he's a science man
he's a mannequin for science
he likes the facts and he wears them and
he wears them well we're happy to have
him here today Mr Neil deGrasse Tyson
out loud
[Music]
sit and tell you my story
[Music]
there's an old joke
uh
there's a guy
his name is Tex
and people said
why they call you text
are you from Texas
and he said
no I'm from Louisiana
and he said why they call you texts
he said because I don't want anyone
calling me Louise
I could see that
that was just a cute something from the
1960s what old old sort of old-timer
old-timey joke yeah that's one of one of
my favorite jokes is uh
they have this guy Crystal Lee he's a
comedian and he has a joke it says
um oh I saw the first 48 it's a TV show
where they have 48 hours to solve a
crime but really they have as much time
as they want
that's one of my favorite ones
um
and then this one's a little edgier but
it's um what's the last thing you want
to hear when you're giving a [ __ ] to
Willie Nelson
what I'm not Willie Nelson okay I've
heard that somewhere yeah that's not my
joke but it's my favorite joke
and you know the uh George Carlin has a
[ __ ] joke he said uh here's a
sentence that's never been uttered in
the history of the world
stop giving me a [ __ ] or I'll call
the police
and ever since I heard that I said there
are sentences in the world that just
have never been uttered in the history
of the world well that's funny because
Joe Rogan when he says that everything
has been
he says like everything has been done
like you've no no no I'll give an
example okay okay we uh in New York 20
years ago we opened a new facility to
the universe and we have models of
planets and molecules and things that
are dangling so you get the size the
relative sizes of things I gave a tour
of the facility to Martha Stewart wow
okay
She's All That by the way because as
we're walking around and it was like a
display surface she's like
oh tidy she was taking the fingerprints
off the off the off the he's probably
taking her fingerprints off she's been
guilty or something so Watch What
Happens we're walking around and and we
have these orbs and she says
Dr Tyson
you have dust on your molecules and I
thought I said wow that sentence has
never been spoken in the history of the
universe that's fine see I think that's
it I agree with that kind of stuff right
yeah one time I was on his show and the
first thing he said he's like you know
there's been another theovan there's
been another in a like there's just he
wants to Multiverse to be another one of
you oh we can go there we can go that's
what he goes into but you actually in
your uh did we begin yet we all up in
the beginning I think we're rolling
we're rolling yeah yeah we're good Let
It Go I love what you've done with the
place by the way oh that's very nice
we're just about to get up we're we're
getting a new studio so we're we're
getting close to the end of the time
don't make it too impersonal I mean make
sure the studio is still intimate just
feels intimate yeah yeah I agree it's
important right yeah yeah otherwise what
are you doing you know you're on stage
you know and that's not the point of a
podcast dude that's a great point
because we've been looking at places and
I'm like I don't want something that's
too corporate or something no it doesn't
feel right it ain't right it ain't right
yeah feels like more you want and when
you're on stage that's you be on stage
that's different right yeah here we're
chilling yeah yeah we're killing you
wanted to feel that way yeah exactly
that's a great point I'm glad you I'm
really glad you said that because I
needed some affirmation there
um but in your book in Starry Messengers
so this is your new book right and
thanks for for checking it out yeah yeah
yeah definitely I tried to check out as
much as I just as much as like
um I had time to kind of uh here's what
you do you're here in La you're in L.A
okay you get the audiobook and then when
you're stuck in traffic you just
three days of traffic get through the
book just fine right that's how they
should Market them how many days of 405
traffic you know four days of traffic
um but one thing he said about it was
individual that the end of their uh you
you kind of almost did a little bit of
an equation on the individual it's kind
of towards the later in the book you
talked about it was just like
that each person is unique and you kind
of went into you went straight there
yeah oh my gosh because yeah that's the
life and death chapter so there's so
just tell me about that I just want
people to hear how unique they are oh
yeah okay so just the book is at Cosmic
perspectives on civilization and it's
what the world looks like if you're
scientifically literate and you have a
and and you're thinking about Earth from
space and the world looks really
different not just the world physically
but people's interactions are different
you have some strongly held opinion and
I say no you don't you think you you
think you've deeply thought this through
right but you haven't there's this part
of it and have you thought about this
and have you thought about that I'm not
here to hand you an opinion I just want
to make sure that whatever opinion you
do have is deeply is is rationally
formed that you that you've folded all
the information together then I walk
away and think how the hell you want I
don't care yeah I think yeah it
definitely helps like adjust maybe the
scope of stuff like if you're looking at
some from this angle what about look at
it from this side or what about it look
at it from the inside or what about a
look at it from the history of its
beginning like exactly and a quick one
before I get to the the uh how unique we
are uh just a quick one you know I don't
know if you you buy tuna uh now when you
buy tuna it's very clear whether it's
line clot tuna oh really mine caught
okay that's a big selling point because
when it's not wine caught it's net
caught
you know what happens when they drag a
net occasionally they drag a dolphin
dolphins are air breathing so if they're
caught in the net they suffocate and die
oh okay you don't want that so you get
line caught tuna and I'm just thinking
so for people who just care about that
I'm just I wonder
what about the tuna just cares about the
two do you just not give a rat's ass
about the tuna wait what what what
and it's and and and then they said well
dude kills the dolphin unnecessarily or
so so then I said well then make dolphin
Burgers okay he said you can't have that
and I said well why not you go to the
deli yeah okay if a deli made Dolphin
salad sandwiches they'd be picketing out
front wouldn't there okay I'd have a cut
of it
look at your Theo Von I love it we had
owl one time at Thanksgiving oh
Thanksgiving oh man okay so uh my point
is if you
if you go to a deli you and there'd be
picketers out front if you're serving
Dolphins
no watch but what else does the deli
serve they sell dead chicken dead turkey
dead salmon dead pig dead cow with with
roast beef dead vegetables I'll get to
that in a minute but they sell all kinds
of dead animals in a sandwich
and this is just another dead animal but
somehow we culturally philosophically we
we've divided up the all the kingdoms of
life and we do carve outs yeah for what
we want to protect and what we don't and
often that carve out is arbitrary at
some level yeah and just be self-aware
of that are you high and Noble because
you're saving the dolphin but you're
eating the tuna right I don't know that
you entirely are civil dolphin is a
mammal well so are pigs and cows all
right last I checked yeah okay they're
just I think people they're not as
graceful they don't they can't do as
many well most of them admit that say I
will not eat graceful animals right I'll
only eat clumsy animals that are ugly
so it's a it's an attempt to just make
you more honest yeah with yourself about
the opinions you carry there's another
one let's say you're a vegetarian this
is from the chapter meat eaters and
vegetarians okay I go there because you
know
saying that's what I'm saying each
chapter is a is a point of conflict in
Civilization I'm trying to illuminate
places where people could think
differently or maybe not have to think
that way at all because in fact what
they felt would was deeply held argument
really just evaporates in the face of a
cosmic perspective so here's one you're
a vegetarian because you just don't want
to kill animals okay you you don't want
to kill a fine
so in your basement you have a Humane
mouse trap okay oh yeah I've seen that
you've seen those yeah they some of them
it's like a little it goes It goes in it
gets an art on the walls inside of it
it's inside it's like a mouse
condominium all right yeah so they go in
you got to check them every few days
every few days because they'll they'll
dry out all right so anyhow so you check
it and then you and what do they do with
the mouse once they capture it let it
free they let it free into the wall all
right because they don't want to kill
animals all right I get that but do you
realize that a mouse in the wild
lives between 9 and 18 months because
it's highly likely to be swallowed whole
by a owl or pecked apart by all manner
of Woodland Predators okay carnivores
and so so what you've done is Doom
you've doomed the mouse
to be eaten prematurely in its life so
the best thing you can do for the mouse
is leave it in your basement where it
will live sex up to six years of a full
fat life in your basement but you're not
doing that no because yeah so I guess it
makes us feel like some type of noble if
we transfer it I'm just saying but
you're really putting into a harder life
in a harder life correct so if so if you
want to say well that's just Nature's
Loop and circle well all right so you're
saying it's nature Circle to have a owl
eat it then by the way if you crawled
into the domicile of any animal
they'll kill you if they could
they'll kill them they will kill your
ass yeah they don't care bro if you if
you lay down into an ant nest they will
bite you
so so all right but oh no we have the
intellect and the power to capture
something and remove it from your home
and I'm just saying if you cared about
the mouse you'd leave it in your
basement yeah that's all that's that's
my only Point yeah I think well that's a
good point a lot of a lot of this book
is like that it's kind of I thought it
was nice about the book that you can
kind of pick it up whenever you can kind
of almost start in on any cash yeah
because the chapters are independent of
each other and but and each one is a is
a is a way in a way a chapter on the
things we all argue about yeah the
chapter on on there's a one on politics
you know are you left wing right wing
what are you arguing about and why and
have you really thought it through
there's the vegetarians and meat eaters
there's there's
um a chapter on life and death risk and
reward
that one there's a gap in the human mind
I have no other way to account for this
where we do it is not natural to think
about statistics and probability oh yeah
it's not natural and did you know that
that doesn't feel as much fun sometimes
that's true it ruins something what you
want to be true or what you feel to be
true yeah or the mystery it takes away
the mystery and but it's a Triumph of
human intellect that we even went could
figure it out in the first place here's
what you have you go to you go to Vegas
and and there's someone puts money on a
seven on a roulette and I'll say why are
you sticking with the seven let's say
it's due and they're looking at and and
the roulette table they have a list of
all the previous numbers yeah and they
say it hasn't shown up it's due no it's
not it's not due every role has the same
probability every time every time it's
not do all right what is so what is that
feeling then that we get what is that I
feel I'm telling you I'm telling other
things that people rolling Dice and they
need a low number like a three or four
so the roll the light the dice gently
and if they need a high number they'll
throw it hard no and so so do you know
who exploits this about us casinos
casinos know we suck at math and
probability and statistics so they exist
other human beings learn this about
human beings and created an entire
industry to exploit it damn it's sad
My People my people the American
physical Society physicist
um this is back in the 80s they were
going to have their annual meeting in in
San Diego and there was a snafu with the
hotel reservations Vegas said we'll take
you you got four thousand people at the
MGM said we'll take you so all the
physicists went to Vegas and we know
probability and statistics we understand
the fact that basically you don't win
relative to the casino at the end of the
week there was a news headline
physicists in town lowest Casino take
ever
[Laughter]
so it's just it's sad like almost the
saddest chapter that I wrote well why do
we feel that so what is that feeling
that makes us feel like is it a feeling
that we create is it or where does that
come from that makes us feel like this
is it it's because we don't have the
brain wiring to know otherwise
I have no other accounting for it we
just don't
think by the way that branch of math was
one of the last to be discovered do you
realize probability and statistics was
developed and discovered after calculus
wow you can pick I think it's because
the brain doesn't even know how to go
there I have a I have a research paper
from the mid 1700s which it feels like a
long ago but a lot of math had been
developed before that including calculus
and in that paper it says I've just
discovered how helpful it is to take an
average of numbers
right that's pretty normal that's normal
stuff and somebody had to discover this
WOW about the world and so so we yeah I
guess we don't want because do you think
also at that time there was a lot
there's also back then there's more
sorcery there's more Wizards yeah
there's more less than than the Middle
Ages and stuff but right there's still a
few Milling around yeah a few and and so
and so I think people there's a little
bit more mysticism then so probability
probably is something it probably would
be the last thing you think about if
somebody over here is you know Hester
prenance somebody at a dam that that's a
perception party what you're saying I
think is because we had Sorcerers and
wizards and people with mysterious
powers and shamans and things they could
live
in the mystery of the probability and
statistics and you think it's a power
that they wield and so there's no urge
to try to decode it because it's their
powers right yeah so I agree with you I
think right they hadn't really debunked
all those powers and religion was really
at the at the on everyone's breath so
there was a lot more I think uh mystery
and it's not just probably even
physiology so for example you go back
you know three four hundred years if you
fell on the ground
writhing and frothing at the mouth
people would think you were winning
something from God no no it's no no no
no you J and you're doing this and
you're shaking the devil just occupied
your Bible boy that's what the devil
looks like and feels like so oh my gosh
the devil's there let me go to get the
priest so you're in a small town how far
away is the church it's two blocks away
okay so you go down you know you could
be choking on the damn muffin okay
you know what I'm saying it could be but
I'm specifically referring to that
condition okay you're frothing at the
mouth okay so they get the priest the
priest gets the robe the holy water the
crucifix they go to on location they
bless them put the and then the symptoms
go away oh now you're healed by the
priest that is the exact and it was a
seizure and it was a seizure it was an
epileptic seizure epileptic seizure
matches the time scale of you going to
get a priest down the block in a small
town yeah okay wow and so boom why think
it's anything but the devil this episode
is sponsored by betterhelp
that's right
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual
you won't find when you can check your
pockets check your pants
check your crevasses check your check
out chat go ahead check feel around feel
yourself
there's no user manual so when life
isn't working for you it's normal that
you can feel stuck hell
I felt so damn stuck I'd feel like I'm
got glue on me I'm glued out
navigating life's challenges can be
challenging that's why better help is
here to help
better help therapists are trying to
help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine that you and
me can be
betterhelp has connected over three
million people with licensed therapists
it's convenient and accessible anywhere
a hundred percent online
whether you've been in therapy or
haven't been in therapy better help is
it's interesting because you can get a
therapist right there you get one
and they'll help you find one in person
help you find one on
um on the screen you can just talk on
the phone whatever's comfortable for you
if the therapist isn't working it's easy
to it's easy to change therapists you
don't have to be in the office
explaining to them
you just send a message say I want to
try someone different and boom there you
are
and I encourage you to find someone that
really fits try a couple out before you
land somewhere
as the world's largest therapy service
better help us match three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking switch no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better h-e-l-p
etherhelp.com
Theo we are so so I don't blame people
for this it's just the reality of
Discovery and and if you question what
you see and and find ways to to
experiment with it and you'll realize no
it is not the devil it is epilepsy
that's uncontrolled firing of your the
synapses of your brain it's still a you
know a tragic Affliction that's not
entirely cured we can control it with
drugs and things but that's an example
of the mystery that existed back then do
you believe in the devil
I remain unconvinced that such a thing
exists dang you challenging him
by the way Jews don't think of hell just
to Jews into heaven but no hell and
therefore there's no devil oh wow that's
in taking the easy way
that's why I hadn't thought about it
that way yeah and it's better Real
Estate too if you're if you're I feel
like if you're advertising it like that
like others are Heaven yeah yeah don't
worry about the hell right right right
right maybe they needed less forces of
control over their conduct than the
Christians later did I don't know yeah
that's one thing about Christianity man
is too sometimes it's like too much
pressure well yeah and no one could
fulfill that no one can live up to
possible which is why here's another one
in the spirit of your earlier comment
here's another one
oh you got sick and this person didn't
God is punishing you you did something
against God in the last two weeks yeah
you were touching your privates all
right whatever I mean we all do stuff oh
I do
and it's and it's easy to find it and
say oh my gosh I must be punished for
that and and when that happens then you
blame starts getting handed out so here
I got another one consider consider that
Muslims the it's part of the rituals of
being a Muslim is you're cleaning your
hands and your feet and you're and your
ears and your nose and there's there's
an ablution whatever the word is where
you there's a cleansing daily wow daily
okay good idea my grandmother I think
was Muslim then well just think but just
think about this back then nobody's
showering every day nobody people's but
some funky times okay all right there's
some people don't shower every day today
but you could and United States we
probably take more showers than anybody
else in the world from the research I've
done on that but point is
if a disease comes through and it comes
from contact or or some other thing
because you're dirty
you get sick and the Muslims don't oh so
they seem powerful oh my gosh and you're
Christian and they're Muslims you're
saying they put us a hex on me these
heathens these non-jesus following okay
wow this is how this can happen I got
another one you ready so now I'm still
around the last one you had one you
ready you got okay here it goes all
right so we would later learn that many
of the plagues uh-huh uh were from a
flea
okay like from a um like a little fly oh
yeah there's a fleet just regular
regular flea that the house flea that
you get on yeah yeah and pets okay so
now watch so the flea would get infected
and would bite you and you'd get the
plague okay okay the plagues have killed
more people than practically any more
than Wars okay wow all right so
so wow plague is like a blight on you
all right so now Watch What Happens
where did the fleas come from we would
later learn they came from rats and mice
yeah okay that were infected with the
plague so if your house had rats or mice
and mice were common look at old
Renaissance paintings there's mice in
the corners of the paintings it's really
funny just to see this all right so now
watch
maybe they were good luck huh if you
owned a cat
you didn't have mice
you didn't get to play You're Gonna Get
the plague no wait a minute who owned
cats well there are many women that own
cats
so women didn't get the plague and they
were there for Sorcerers they were
witches
witches and some of them are and and you
still associate a cat with a witch yeah
to this day
to this day I mean when you're when
you're you know storytelling about
items these are the two uh uh
so attachments those are them so these
are this is what happens when you live
in a pre-scientific era wow the blame
game begins but that's fun as hell some
of it well for a movie but I don't want
to live in those times yeah so this book
is an attempt to unravel this blame game
when you see things happening it's not
my fault it's your fault but did you
really look through your opinions and
your thoughts and and and it was neat
some of it made me mad ah good good some
of them are like [ __ ] out a woman
no no it's mad because you knew it you
knew it's true and it's against your
urges yeah it was like damn Neil I want
to believe what I want to believe you
know that's what it felt like sometimes
but no but I'm not I don't think I'm
heavy-handed I think it's their
offerings right have you thought about
it this way yeah no I don't think it
came off like I'm trying kind of think
no I don't think it came off as like no
at all I think it was like I don't it
wasn't my intent right if it ever felt
that way that was it's just well you're
a fat guy you're a factor you're a man
you know and uh you know I battle you
know like I think I've always kind of
battled the dark arts overall so it's
like I've never really looked at a ton
of the facts you know it's always been
this more ethereal sort of but what you
feel what what you want to be true
rather than what is true and by the way
that's uh that that's that's coming a
long way in life to realize the world
this is the difference between the
different kinds of truths I spent a
chapter in the truth in Beauty chapter I
just talk about I'll just say spend a
minute on it now so there's something I
call personal truths this is something
no one's going to take in a free Society
no one's going to take it from you if
Jesus is your savior and you know true
to your bones that's a personal truth in
a free society and especially in the
United States where it's
constitutionally protected your freedom
of religion no one should take that from
you okay you'd have a legal case if they
try all right other personal truths oh
well uh Muhammad is my last savior on
Earth my last prophet on Earth okay that
this would be a Muslim personal truth
other truths are Beyonce is your queen
right or whatever the things you feel
okay
personal truths are the foundation of
our strongest held opinions
and in a pluralistic world society that
we should cherish that this is why
people are different from each other all
right you don't want everybody to be the
same oh that's called a a dictatorship
yeah if everybody aligns with exactly
the same yeah they don't want it the
problem with your opinion if it's in a
personal truth if you try to have
someone else agree with you
you have to have an act of persuasion so
what but in the limit that becomes
all-out conflict and War
people fight over personal truths kill
each other because their personal truths
don't agree with your personal truth so
personal truths when they go outside of
yourself
risk Bloodshed right in the history of
civilization has demonstrated this all
right then there's a political truth
which is just something that becomes
true just because you heard it often
enough and that's a weakness we have and
not a weakness evolutionarily it made
sense if you see something repeat a
hundred times that's reality oh yeah
okay but you know what happens now
we would people have hijacked that urge
to recognize that something that repeats
must be true they've hijacked it now
they just find something that they want
to be true and they repeat it to you you
hear it enough it must be true yeah
there it is yeah this Festival nowadays
also we have you know since we have
technology and we have this advancement
like you know with the internet social
media it's so it's easy to get things in
front of people so many times yes it's
easy to I mean our attention span has
been high project it's been hijacked
completely that's the word there's no
other word but hijacked and in the old
days we called it brainwashing where you
repeat something and then it becomes
true that's hijacking this feature of
our evolutionary brain that it's trying
to create order out of chaos like
Stockholm syndrome we almost are slowly
developing almost uh some variance it
seem like of a Stockholm syndrome or
something like we're like all like
Elizabeth's smart you know without the
or Elizabeth dumb that's who we're
becoming you know saying we're all like
you know we don't we're just bearing
with what we have to deal with all the
time exactly and so you try to sift
through what is true and it must be that
which was repeated often enough that's a
political truth then there's an
objective truth okay what does objective
mean and the methods and tools of
science are exquisitely tuned to
establish objective truth so these are
truths that have been demonstrated by
observation and experiment and repeated
experiment what is the word objective
objective means
it's true whether or not you believe in
it okay so it's no doubt true yeah
because I can show that it's true and
it's not my bias that thinks it's true
here's the data now you see and I don't
believe you I think you had a bias I I
think your wall current affected this so
I'm gonna do it on 240 volts while you
did yours on 125 volts okay 20 volts you
do a different experiment of your own
design you get the same result
so that's objective it's a fact when you
do it enough times and that all
experiments are great this is this is
why science
uh it wasn't really developed as we now
practice it until around 1600 all right
I know that feels like a long time ago
but a lot of the world unfolded before
then all right and so once we learn if
you say something is true let me test it
let me let me find out let me devise an
experiment and if I can verify your
statement with this experiment and
someone else can in a third person we're
good here that's an objective truth and
what objective truths have going for
them is that they're true whether or not
you believe in them I don't like them
well because the actual nature can't be
fooled
nature is the ultimate judge jury and
executioner yeah if you overeat this
week and you gain three pounds next week
you can't protest with placards saying I
protest the law of gravity because it
made me heavier no you don't have that
option
so it seems to me if you're going to
base laws on things
uh but there's a whole chapter in here
on on Law and Order right if you're
going to create laws in a pluralistic
world you base the laws on the objective
truth right because that applies to
everyone don't base a law on your
personal truth because that's forcing it
on me and I have a different personal
truth is climate change an objective
truth oh yes
oh yes so what happens is you believe in
climate change it's not a belief it's
not about a belief right it's but it's
when it's objectively true you don't
have to believe it it just is true yeah
I believe in it when it's really hot I
believe in it it's like a hot day I'm
like damn they're right they're right
about oh [ __ ]
I'm serious dude so I'm like we gotta
fight this so so here's the thing so so
if it was only determined that way then
another person that was in a cold snap
would say no I don't believe it right
and everybody's making up their own
theories about it because they're it's
their own life experience but an
experiment
takes the information out of yourself
okay it's not your perspective it's not
your bias it's not your world view and
you get all the data available and then
you establish the objective truth so so
in climate change and I give an example
here in the probability uh in the risk
and reward chapter
um You probably heard the number 97
scientists say it's happening in three
percent it saw that in here in the last
20 years
um there are basically no scientists
left denying it so it's basically 100
damn right in one hold out but let's go
back to when it was three percent
because that's a fun number okay all
right let's do an experiment some
Engineers there's a bridge that's there
you don't know where it came from but
it's a bridge but it's brand new and
it's about to open and you say I want to
drive my truck across the bridge
and 97 Engineers come up to you and say
but I don't know any of the other
Engineers so we're not in cahoots or
anything yeah um if you drive a truck
that's going to collapse and you're
going to die
you'll likely die plunging into the
Ravine so 97 of them say that three say
oh Theo
go take your F-150 drive across
go on you'll be fine
what are you gonna do making my way
he's feeling it he's feeling just saying
man I take the General Lee off that
Master that's what I'm saying man but no
I hear you so so you would probably
listen to the 97 Engineers especially if
you're not an engineer yourself yeah I'm
thinking if you got to look the
engineers in the eyes now no ice got
nothing to do with this this that's you
trying to be human about this ah don't
be human that mess you up
let me feel what you're saying no
they'll show you the research papers
there's no eyeballs in the research
paper there's no emoticons in the
research paper so then what is that that
makes me want to look him in the eyes
and see what is that oh I'll tell you I
tell you it's a good one it's a good one
uh we and again I think it's
understandable evolutionarily if you
look someone in the eye and they tell
you something that just happened
that is more true to you
than a statistical table with charts
right bar charts then a pie graph then a
pie graph that says the same [ __ ]
thing
so that and advertisers know that they
hijack this okay testimonial but in the
watch they could just show a bar chart
and say this detergent is better than
all the others and here's the data they
could show that but no they show some
parent and a kid and they put it in the
machine they pull it out and look how
clean and the eyewitness testimony
has huge value to our emotions because
another human being is communicating it
right
and so you so so I'll give you another
example you could be it's a little more
obscure but you you read in like
Consumer Reports or whatever that this
one car is like a vacuum a vacuum sure
is the best one and it's working every
time you walk into the vacuum store
because you saw the data and someone's
walking out
saying I will never buy one of these
again it's struck oh you can't say a
vacuum sucks sorry
sorry
uh no this vacuum was awful oh It
reversed and it made my whole place I
would never do this and you you you hear
this the person you don't even know them
but they're not a human and they're
speaking with emotions huge effect on me
and there's there's fire in their gaze
okay you're gonna back out and walk out
of that store I ain't getting that you
ain't getting ain't getting nothing not
gonna happen broom I'd rather use a
[ __ ] broom okay so I think it's
natural
to trust another human right in that
context
but that's why we have to train
ourselves to trust the data and in
science when you become a scientist I'm
taking statistics and data analysis and
probability essentially every year I'm
in school it's not just one class and
you move on there are different nuances
over there different ways you think
about it different ways you ask
questions you know what science is it's
a professional way of querying nature
so that you can not fool yourself into
thinking something is true that is not
or that something is not true that is
um did I say that right whatever the
opposite you might have I don't know I
was following it was good no no I'd say
that you don't want to be fooled
because nature can't be ultimately
nature economy right and we have biases
where so you don't want
do whatever it takes I'm going to give
you the scientific method do whatever it
takes and I'm going to reword repeat
that do whatever it takes
to not fool yourself into thinking
something is true that is not or that
something is not true that is doesn't
mean getting a video of it does it mean
getting getting someone else to check on
you did you have your coffee this
morning or not is that the measure were
you more alert did you miss something
right do whatever it takes and when you
do that it ain't got nothing to do with
the passion in their eyes oh
just okay now so let's take this into a
something that is the a realm that
doesn't have as much probability
probably go for it so let's take it into
the realm of love right love it or
affection things like that so whenever
you met are you married yes I married 34
years oh wow oh yeah congratulations
thank you man wow that is a damn record
almost you should win a Nobel Prize for
that I met her in relativity class she
doesn't really agree in mathematical
physics dang yeah in graduate school so
that was fun yeah better in relativity
that's wild
um so all right so you're talking about
love okay love so do you I mean are you
do you take these same Concepts into
like whenever you were falling in love
and stuff like that or was it more like
a normal okay so starring class so so
the answer is yes I do why I don't often
talk about this you want to hear you
want to hear it yeah well I'm just
curious because I don't have a wife or
anything yet but it's mathematical okay
then this could be helpful to you okay
okay it could be helpful okay all right
at this point I'll take on any it's a
little bit of mathematical okay how much
mass have you had in school I took a
couple of them you took a couple
I took at least yeah a couple of
weeks I was good I did all right you did
all right you did all right okay one of
them at high altitude I took one class
out in Arizona at pretty high altitude
you know what they say that if you learn
something under certain psychomotor uh
uh conditions that you recover it better
under those same conditions oh wow like
if you get high and you learn something
if you get high again later you'll learn
you'll remember that better because you
match the mental States oh dang it yeah
I've read that I haven't read it lately
but a few decades ago
I think I wrote that okay so I'm glad it
made it okay so here it is all right
here it is all right um you gotta follow
me with some math here okay okay it's
not complicated by the way I I don't
know any dumb professional comedians you
all are smart people you're perceptive
you know what's going on you have to
know deeper what's going on to come at
it from the other side and show why it's
hilarious okay that takes Insight you
guys are the keepers of the Soul
of the social and cultural mores of
civilization yeah I think a lot of us
try to be Jesus I don't know what I'm
doing but I think a lot of us try to do
our best yeah you're holding up Windows
not Windows mirrors to what we think say
and do and so it's a fundamental part I
think of modern
existence because without it my gosh how
how how unpleasant the world would be it
would have these perspectives that's my
I'm not just blowing smoke I'm just
saying and you especially have a certain
authentic honesty that is palpable and
it's like whatever you say I'm with you
on I feel you this is what he was saying
do you feel what the person if I can't
feel what you're saying go home right
right what are you doing you just just
type it up and send you know text it to
me I if I if I'm not looking and you're
in the eyes you know so okay yeah well
it's helping me because it's like you
know I think I have a I'm not like a
naysayer of science I love you know I'm
grateful for science because I exist and
I'm grateful that the world exists and
that we're able to have all types of
different experiences of like caring
about each other and getting to travel
and see different things and then my
eyes work like I'm super grateful for
science I think sometimes I get a fur
like I have a fear sometimes of like if
anything's out of like the vid like out
of like right here everything else can
seem a little bit questionable you know
so I think it's just uh you know it says
probably the questionable part is
because you you create your own world
view yeah and you're and you everything
makes sense to you in your world view
and something's trying to poke it from
the outside you're understandably
skeptical of it yeah yeah I'm probably
skeptical I'm rejecting it because no I
got my thing my my situation it works
for me yeah and I like to just I like to
daydream and stuff you know so science
sometimes they want to really hey bro
you know we need you to pull these
Daydreams over here and uh we gotta tag
them you know we just we need to get the
weight in the uh and the density of
these Daydreams so we can have them on
file so I respect it
um and I'm really really grateful that
you're here
um but yeah so tell me about that when
you went into so here it is and this is
a little geeky yeah it was a geeky thing
so
all right
um
you can have a line and you can measure
the length of the line okay
right whatever okay uh that's the only
thing you can measure about it there's
no area there's no volume it's just a
length
all right now I can add another line at
like right angles to it
and when I do that
I can actually Trace out a square okay
so now A square has more than just a
length it has area
okay this area inside the square and
that area is defined by both both axes
you need both to get an area okay all
right let's add a third axis oh now X Y
now Z now you don't have a y you don't
have a square what do you have you have
a cube now my mushrooms I think you have
a cube that's full each of these right
so now it's a dimension okay right so
now watch now I can take that to higher
Dimensions but I won't I would stick to
three okay we can go to four in five
dimension let's stick to three so now
you ask yourself
what do you care about in a relationship
okay it wants a person to look hot
nothing wrong with that
make a note of that okay
um you want the person to be good and
bad okay that it's not just fine be
honest with yourself that's another by
the way you can be hot and not good in
bed oh yeah or vice versa okay so so
these are separate
coordinates
okay okay so all right now watch let's
get a third one uh you want the person
to be kind let's say kind you want an
evil evil person no okay no so each of
these is completely separate from the
other you can be beautiful and and evil
you can be ugly and kind but you can be
but you care about those three right so
now rate this person from zero to ten in
those three categories just go ahead and
do that so you say
um a person's really kind and they're
great in bed only give them a five okay
in looks the green bed and they're kind
all right here's what you do you know
how you get the volume of a cube you
multiply X by y by Z okay the area of a
square is is x times y the area of a the
volume of a cube is you multiply all
three I'm telling you to take those
three numbers multiply them together
you will get the volume
of your love the volume of what you care
about
okay so now watch now here's my point
what you need to do
is because presumably you're if you're
in the field the different people out
there get each person's volume
and go after the person that has the
largest volume
because they might be higher in one than
the other but if you really care about
them it's the total the totality of that
package that matters
especially in a relationship those
features don't always stay the same they
could vary yeah sometimes they grow
better looking as they get older or they
might you might get more attracted to
them or less attractive or less
attractive so there's very much
different skills often some of them get
less you know yeah it's a mix it's a mix
so let's say they get a little less
attractive but the other bits were
strong so you have a volume a strength
of a larger volume to work against okay
if things start uh shifting okay in this
okay I'm telling you you can take that
to higher Dimensions so it really bad
what are they hot are they have a maybe
a good sense of humor something you
might think oh yeah for sure okay
um are they curious
do they want to keep learning okay
that's important do you have of course
why wouldn't it be all right because I
want them to keep learning about me
because or no that's just no that's
selfish if they're if they're curious
you're part of what they want to keep
okay that's fair no no dude no you're
right okay so I sir so I went around
with a five-dimensional uh so in math we
call it five-dimensional Vector space
so that's what I did okay so what I'm
saying is there could be someone who's
the hottest person you've ever seen
and and and you could be distracted by
that and so I'm marrying that person and
then they're not so hot 10 years from
now or they get a little chubby whatever
you're valuing or not evaluating and
then all of a sudden everything you
marry the person for isn't there anymore
and then you divorce seven years later
so you gotta look at that volume got to
look at the volume and by the way be
crass if you want to be crashed do you
want to marry someone who's wealthy put
that in there too put it in there okay
don't be ashamed of that because right
because any one of these can change
people say oh I want just that's shallow
you need the personality people's
personalities can change why are we
sometimes ashamed to look at the
criteria we honestly want to look at I I
got my I got through that I matured out
of that
because because Society wants you to not
want that and if someone is honest I'd
like your wealth I enjoy it and by the
wealth can go away too in the same way
you're looking all the all the things
can but if it matters too then it's one
of the coordinates in this volume by the
way
if any of those go to zero
because the volume is a product you're
multiplying these numbers if anything
goes to zero the volume goes to zero oh
really yes oh because you do you're not
adding them you're multiplying them wow
so so
try to make sure that the likelihood of
it going to zero is or if it does go to
zero if you don't matter then it
shouldn't have been in the right it has
to be things that nothing could go to
zero so then but and if you do that then
you're probably going to be picking
things that have some real value to you
that correct overall value correct
objective or just be honest I just want
money and if you if you run out of money
I'll divorce you right and but the
person could be fun and happy the whole
other time oh yeah they're buying
sandwiches for everybody y'all are
having a good time or whatever you know
that's people are their own individuals
so what happened what happened when you
got delayed you you invite her out
where'd you take or where do you
oh well we you know we were graduate
students at the time you know very poor
you know so a big meal is like a 12 oh
yeah good dish and uh so
um oh oh I have to say this if if I'm
airing all the thing so I took her for
granted initially oh and and we broke up
initially and then I and then like six
months I said what the hell did I just
do
oh my gosh I went back to that volume
and I said all these other people are
not feeling that volume the way she did
and I was really sad did you go back to
her and tell her I was I could because I
broke up I can't but you can't do that
she knocked on my door
she came back to me and what'd she say
and I don't remember because I was
distracted by the fact that oh my gosh I
have a second chance here wow and so on
that second chance that's when we moved
in together and got married three years
later and he didn't mess it up the
second time no no no and and the
strength of a marriage is is how how big
is that volume because yes they will
vary and people will get crabby and
people you know you there are things
that will test it of course with
something that you and your wife like to
do together is there anything like that
do you feel like helps keep a marriage
together over time is there any you do
things together yeah you just and do new
things together so that you have a new
memory to add to the portfolio if you
always do the same old things it can get
you know you see the person every day of
your life right and so so just make sure
it grows have you take do you guys take
like classes or is there stuff like uh
do you just take walks like what are
some fun stuff yeah we do take walks in
fact I should take walks with my
ex-girlfriend I liked it yeah walks are
simple they're low budget
let's go another Block it's an
incidental fact about it not the not the
instrumental fact okay hey baby I love
you because every step is cheap no
that's not that's not gonna fly is that
why you're not married yet it could be
probably I gotta start investing more
here's the thing we all are fairy tales
you see the courtship which is so
romantic and beautiful and and how do
those fairy tales end what's the final
word
um final phrase the end no before that
oh um happily ever after they live
happily ever after wait a minute why
don't you show me some of that oh yeah
that's true give me some hints how do
you pull that one off yeah like Rapunzel
they don't show you that she's selling
her hair in China you know what I'm
saying they don't show you it'll show
you the odds leave that one out so we
we're trained in the courtship and then
we'll say this snow white as an opioid
they don't show you some of the truth
a dealing with actual life problems and
challenges yeah or that uh Goldilocks is
in the bestiality they don't show you
some of the troops out there Neil damn
you're right bro that's what I'm saying
they just gave us the Goldilocks are
sleeping with the with the Bears you
know it's whatever I know they don't
tell you that she has a crush on uh Gail
Sayers you know they don't tell you
she's out there been running around with
Jim McMahon they don't tell you all of
that right so we we have no no literary
life experience even thinking about what
happens Beyond they lived happily ever
after so you have to sort of discover
that on your own is that band is it do
you feel like is it hard for you to let
is it this is it just your was it just
the brain you were given that made you
more scientific
um or was it like uh do you feel like it
was a nature or nurture like that you
develop that as um because as it was a
skill that you needed to help process
your own like life and childhood that's
an important and perceptive question and
I have to unpack that because you put a
lot in that one because we talk about
that kind of stuff a lot on this show
excellent I'll go there let me go there
right now so
I
everyone wants the secret to things
what's the secret to intelligence the
secret to this that implies it's only
one thing and not something more complex
and so I remember when I was a kid this
is a slight off ramp but I hope it's
worth it when I was a kiss it was in
seventh grade I did a book report on
Ponce de Leon and he's the guy the
Spanish explorer who went into South
America searching for the Fountain of
Youth
okay you drink from it and you have
eternal life and I remember reading that
and I say that idiot why would he even
think that exists he's going to commit
an entire Voyage to to believe that
there's just some Elixir coming out of
the ground and he lives forever really a
full-grown human being believe this I
was thinking to him I was already I was
a geeky kid okay yeah I'm I'm 12 I think
at this point but I did the book report
on him and then I noticed as I got older
this is something deep within us
nobody actually wants to do the hard
work to improve their health to live
longer healthier lives they want the
instant fix yeah and realizing that
Ponce de Leon was looking for the
Fountain of Youth allowed me to see what
people were doing
I'm old enough to remember yogurt eat
yogurt that you live forever Dannon had
a commercial with centogenarians eating
yogurt oh yeah okay I'm her mom would
eat the yogurt I'd be like damn mom's
gonna be around but that's what I'm
saying so you we're we're we we want
there to be quick fixes for things and
quick answers and quick Solutions what's
the latest kale kale eat did you eat
your kale today no if not you would die
you're gonna die a miserable death okay
you'll be dead by noon yeah there's
definitely and kale is
so hard to eat you know it feels like it
does not want you eating it if you had
bacon too yeah look I ain't saying
nothing but it is what it is baby they
knew that with collard greens they put
in the ham hockey you wanna eat leaves
put some dead animals
dude you could put bacon under a damn
corpse and I'll [ __ ] have a little
actually actually you know what
um cannibals called humans long Pig
really yeah
because of all the animals that you
would eat the humans and pigs come
closest
but it tastes like bacon you have to
cure it and do the things whatever but
anyhow uh I have some cured human a
little yeah I'm just saying would you
have any uh if I were starving I mean I
have you know I have yeah I see you dog
no no I'm starving hey bruh no wait wait
if I'm in a mountain and the help is not
coming and people died in the plane
wreck otherwise we will starve to death
I'm eating me some dead humans that is
not that isn't I'm not thinking what are
you eating first what part you think uh
not muscle tissue I would say you know
the bicep maybe or or I would I would
take my cue from from just what you'd
get in the store ribs are some good
eating I love ribs
yeah yeah so no I wouldn't hesitate it's
not about morals it's about survival
yeah so so but by the way if there's a
pig over there I'm eating a pig I'm not
eating the dead human yeah that would be
weird if you're like I'm gonna have
Randy
instead of Pumbaa I'm eating Pumbaa okay
Puma ain't surviving the day okay
so that'd be crazy there's one dude at
the plane crash and he just wants to
keep eating the people like but do we
have and pigs and cows and turkeys and
chickens what are you doing
he crashes on a farm right yeah he
crashes into 7-Eleven and he's still
over there cutting up an old lady we got
some creeps out there man so now I'm
completely distracted what the hell was
I talking about Zach
um
um I I don't we kind of went out you
were talking about you know I don't know
you started about bacon it's been a long
road I don't know I know it has uh just
no we were talking about love love no we
got off we okay we evolved evolved uh oh
oh I remember how do I how did I become
me okay okay oh yeah so did this yeah
did you do you think you developed a
sense for science out of nature or
nurture so watch so I'm
walking through life watching people
want to believe that simple things will
fix everything those are the YouTube
uh ads that get your attention
you've been doing too many sit-ups just
do this and you'll have ripped ABS just
eat this drink this and it'll be and you
don't have to do any of that work and I
thought to myself
there must be something deep within us
that just wants to be lazy about what
our accomplishment our accomplishments
okay yeah but that's a kind of an off
ramp just to say
I'm not I don't care about nature or
nurture what I care about is that
whatever you are
you know
you can improve it
you know this
in practically everything we do
you get better at it from trying
from practicing in practically
everything we do so I'm not going to say
nature nurture
people say oh well Michael Phelps he's
got really flexible big feet that flap
in the for swimming and he can fly me
he's got webbed fingers I don't know
he's a long head okay
I don't know but they'll say whatever
they will about his body but wait a
minute uh he's in the water 30 hours a
week yeah did you factor that in is that
where's that in your equation right for
him succeeding how about that okay so
generally you part the curtains
someone's working really hard at what
might look easy to them that they have
accomplished right so I and I don't
think that about you I feel like you've
obviously put in the um what is it the
hours that it takes to have your
credibility so let me get back to your
point so when you were a kid wondering
it's very simple
it's very simple all kids are curious
about everything they overturn rocks and
you know poke things and generally
create chaos at home and most of what
parents do is they spend the first years
of the kids life teaching them to walk
and talk and then the rest of their life
tell them to shut up and sit down
because they're wherever they go they
make a mess but that mess the parents
think they're making a mess but no
they're not these are the results of
experiments they've been doing to
discover the operations of nature
if you happen to leave an egg up on the
counter and a little toddler and because
you're making breakfast and the toddler
is reaching up you say No don't touch
that
and I'm saying no let him grab it let
him
what did the egg cost you last I checked
40 cents at most watch
you know the egg is going to end up
breaking but so what once the kid starts
playing with the egg yeah and then they
do something with it and then it breaks
that's interesting something can be hard
yet fragile hmm how many things in life
are that most of Life eggs are hard and
no most things are solid this is hard
and not fragile but a lot of experiences
in the world and stuff I mean well no
that should be thinking emotional and
I'm talking about physical objects at
this point the egg is hard but fragile
okay and so that's they'll learn about
that very fascinating and it's brittle
it doesn't bend it breaks yeah okay so
these are structural properties of
organic substances all right and then
what's inside there's this transparent
goopy stuff and there's a yellow thing
what is that and then you tell them that
might have been a chicken oh my gosh
blow their mind blow their minds and by
the way you see that colorless stuff if
I heat it it turns White
you can watch it change color in front
of your eyes there's this seven science
experiments to do with the kid reaching
for the egg that you didn't want them to
touch and you just squashed that because
you don't want to use the 40 cents yeah
because you want to have a damn quiche
for yourself okay the president of
Harvard once said when people complained
why are you charging so much for edu he
said if you think the cost of education
is high you should try the cost of
ignorance
that's even higher yeah okay so all I'm
saying is
that curiosity is beaten out of us by
the time we're in Middle School
if you retain that Curiosity that
rampant curiosity
you're a scientist a scientist is a kid
who grew up physically but not
emotionally not mentally
if I see some hey what is that let me
poke that let me see what's behind it
and it doesn't have to be a physical
object it could be like fictional
objects I watched the Thor movie and I'm
saying gee I want to know how I wonder
how how much does that hammer weigh I'm
still curious okay wasn't hammerway and
I heard a sentence in the movie that
enabled me to calculate how much is
Hammer weighed wow they say uh hammer
forged in the heart of a Dying star oh
my gosh I'm an astrophysicist we deal in
dying Stars I got this hide some dense
stuff going on in a dying star I filled
out the density and I tweeted it and I
said if Thor's hammer is made of in the
way the movie says it has the weight of
a herd of 300 million elephants ah
that's why nobody could pick it up the
Hulk couldn't pick it up you need the
magical powers of of Thor to do it so
now I saw Lou Ferrigno at the post
office one time luffino both the
original TV yeah the original one yeah
and his wife was making him move boxes
around he was all pissed and I'm like
you're the freaking hole man move a
couple of blocks you know he's got to be
green to do that yeah dude get with the
program he was without his paint but
watch what happened okay because I'm in
the geekiverse yeah I'm thinking yes
I tweeted that out that was like total
nerd alert and then I got out nerded no
oh somebody said uh Dr Tyson is wrong
about this calculation okay so yeah I
got totally smoked on this one so what
happened was in 1991 Marvel issued a
Thor's hammer trading card
where they said Thor's hammer is made of
a fictional material uru
and it weighs precisely 42.3 pounds ah
so they kind of cheated well yeah yeah
but but
uh I I'm getting to your earlier point
I wanted my answer to be true right I
think it's a way better answer
than 42.3 pounds but it's wrong it's in
the cannon in the marble Cannon it's
just simply wrong and you got to know
when to hold them when to uh when to
fold him and went to what's the third
one and when to walk uh when to walk
away we're in a run I think yeah and
that's I think usually out around
alimony yeah yeah hold them fold them
run so so that's an example of still
being curious into a dollar and all
scientists are like that so so no it's
not nurture nature it's did you protect
your curiosity in childhood if not
you'll ossify I love that word you'll
Harden in your own beliefs you won't
even seek out
things that might conflict with what you
think is true and because you're
comfortable where you are right you know
what it is and we want to be where we
are we want to be it's right here it is
well yeah you get you want to yeah you
get from a place of like I'm right and
it's funny because I don't really like
being in that place even there's part of
me that does like it because it feels
like I'm winning
but there's another part of me that
knows it's not helpful to me as a
evolving human which wins
sometimes one when sometimes the other I
think sometimes someone One Way some of
the other but I'm grateful that
that I have that I have awareness of
both and I do find my own way that's
half the effort by the way if you know
that this is going on you're there and
I'm grateful that the one does does
battle a lot of times and say you know I
know you want to sit right here with
this but there's you it's only fair if
you look at more to the story I think I
told her to myself too there's a name
there's a guy named Walter badge hot I
think is his name I quote him in the
book and I think this is the right quote
where he said there's no greater pain of
the human existence than the prospect of
having a new idea because it would just
conflict with what you who you are and
how you've defined yourself yeah so and
why do we want to be why do we want to
stay why do we want to have that
definition I think I know why it's
comfortable here it is here it is you
ready you must have been the worst
person in class you must have been no no
every time the teacher's like does
anybody have an idea you know you must
have brought a fake hand no it just just
put it on your desk straight up every
time every time so no I'm so here's what
I think is going on
you know the Alice Cooper song I don't
know the title of it but I know the
lyric schools for summer schools out
forever okay this is a celebration
of not learning ah
and we know people if not ourselves on
at the end of the school day we can't
wait for the the alarm to go off at the
end of the day or the Friday comes or
more likely the last day of school and
the summer say school's out and you toss
your books in the air and you run down
the steps and I'm thinking to myself
your only job was to learn about this
beautiful world about this Majestic
universe and you're celebrating not
learning and so I'm not going to blame
the people I'm going to blame the school
because if I have you for six hours a
day and you come out and you'd rather
not be there I have failed not in a
little great sense as a teacher I have
failed the system
you know what should be happening in
school I shouldn't be loading you with
textbooks with with with bold face
vocabulary words that you memorize once
for the exam before you move on no no no
I should figure out a way to make you
excited about everything you learn yeah
so that at the end of the school day
you're sad to walk out of school
imagine the world that would be and you
know what schools should do it's not let
me load you with knowledge it's let me
prepare you to be a lifelong learner so
that this curiosity that we have infused
in you in kindergarten through 12 or
kindergarten through 16 if you're in
college there whatever when you come out
that is just the beginning
of the flame that will coerce within you
for the rest of your life because you
will spend much more time not in school
than you ever did in school and once
again I'll use the word again if you
ossify in your knowledge by getting out
of college getting out of high school
if that's if that's where you are
you will never grow the world will leave
you behind and you'll just be the
grumpiest person on the porch say get
off my lawn you what what are these
youngins know I know because you are
comfortable in your ignorance and you
don't even know your ignorance because
you came to it from from Having learned
but only up to a point and without the
Curiosity you don't keep learning
curious It's All About the Curiosity and
the ambition you have attached to it
it's don't tell me about
nature nurture I'm not even I'm not even
thinking that way yeah I think well I
grew up in a place you know I grew up in
a place um
in Louisiana we had you know I've talked
about this before like the uh primate
testing facility where they uh created
the polio vaccine was in our town so
Tulane University didn't know that it's
just a primate testing facility in um in
St Tammany Parish Louisiana and I
remember
one time a bunch of the monkeys had
gotten out right and they came and got
us out of YMCA summer camps the police
did the tallest kids to help them and so
we're out there by like the monkeys on
the trees and you got to reach for him
or how are you going to get them the
monkeys are just out yeah they wanted
like a chain of people I guess oh okay
and so uh By the way when the monkeys
get out there's nowhere that's that's a
scary fact right oh in hindsight knowing
now what I know about monkeys and
chimpanzees I think it was a bad idea oh
okay but at the time we didn't know so
you know it was a smaller town then and
so we're out there just wrangling chimps
out by this Kenny Rogers Roasters he
used to have like a Kenny Rogers had a
uh chicken establishment for a while and
they had like kind of rotisserie chicken
it's pretty good they had like this
cornbread thing they're pretty good but
um but anyway and also in our area
um they had a thing called ligo ligo it
was the it's still there it's um you
know what I'm talking about laser
interferometer gravitational Observatory
yeah there's only two of them in the
well in the United States in Louisiana
and I feel isn't it Louisiana and up in
Oregon or Washington Washington yeah so
that was another thing in our area so
you know there was by the way just to be
clear that is discovering colliding
black holes in other galaxies Across the
Universe damn it's a new kind of
telescope and you got it there in your
home state I knew they were up to
something no yeah and by the monkeys are
running
hey skate monkeys achieved Consciousness
and intelligence I wouldn't be shocked
that's a Planet of the Apes [ __ ] going
on I would not be shocked yet I've seen
some people there that work at some of
the gas stations definitely they have a
banana for lunch I'll say that dude
there's some interesting folks there no
chimpanzees peel the banana from the
bottom you know that yeah yeah you know
what my friend does he breaks the banana
in half if it's if it's unripe yeah
that'll work yes that's true otherwise
you got some mashed banana right there
but we used to hear about
um because they were over there hunting
grass all we heard was that they had
gravity Hunters out there that's that's
a that's a good way that's a poetic way
to put it so that's what we heard and so
there'd be people like if you saw
somebody that could dance real good
you'd say they were like one of those
gravity babies or whatever or sometimes
people would have parties and people
would say oh you know we're gonna get so
and they would live near there by the in
Livingston Parish Louisiana where that
ligo Center is and they'd say we're
going to get so [ __ ] up we can't even
feel the gravity yeah yeah there it is
yeah wow zoom in on that that's crazy
yeah yeah so what's going on there if if
your listeners have access to this
viewers so those are two long tubes and
they send a beam of light from that
Central Building
simultaneously the full length of both
tubes and then there are mirrors at the
end of those two both tubes and it
reflects back and they recombine the
light
and if the light recombines perfectly
then nothing happened between those two
uh Reflections but if a gravitational
wave washes over Earth and goes through
this facility one of those beams will be
slightly delayed compared to the other
they're doing that out there and they
can measure it I know people that can't
read out there they delay and so they're
looking for a variation in a fraction of
the diameter of a proton
and that is a completely evacuated tube
that goes up and back
um so tell me this so say they find a
say say there's some variation what does
that tell them that there's some pull on
there of course it tells you that the
thing actually happened Einstein
predicted the existence of gravitational
waves this discovered them
it's 8 60 70 years later wow okay no no
more than that uh this was 2000 when was
that uh this this Century Einstein made
the prediction in in 1916. so you're
talking basically 100 Years A Century
there's a prediction and then a
discovery and this is this is ground
truth that our ideas actually match
objective reality okay and you want to
say well how does that put food on your
plate it doesn't but it advanced
technology in a way that will surely
have applications later on Einstein
wrote down the first equation in a paper
called on the stimulated emission of
radiation obscure quantum physics paper
in the 1920s okay late teens and why are
you doing that you're a smart guy why
don't you help put food on people's
plates wanna do you know what that's the
foundation of the laser which would not
be built until the 1950s and and lasers
back then were like cost tens of
thousands of dollars in their room size
now they're impulse items at at Walmart
yeah and for laser pointers right oh
yeah but lasers are now you know barcode
now photos can do it but in their day
barcode reading laser surgery LASIK
surgery for your eyes
um laser Cosmetics removal so who oh
lasers you put a laser on anything on
anything and do you think Einstein's
saying yes we're gonna have LASIK
surgery with this equation that I wrote
now nobody's thinking that so the people
say why are we doing this with smart
people when the smart people could be
solving the homeless problem because we
don't know what the future is you don't
know what the future is somebody might
invent a laser that makes home homeless
people happy okay
so you don't know what about this though
so say that thing picks up some sort of
gravitational wave what does it mean it
means that there's a black hole that's
kind of sucking on earth a little bit no
it meant two black holes collided and
the Collision is quite catastrophic and
it sends a ripple
it's like tossing a pebble in a pond
okay and you see the Ripple go out in
all directions except the pond surface
is only two it's flat in space this is a
ripple that goes through full three
dimensions of space and it's moving at
the speed of light and it washes over
Earth at the speed of light and by the
way remember I said make sure you don't
think something that's true that's not
or there's that or isn't true that it
okay so
suppose you're just a mischievous
graduate student and you're in that
facility say I want to I'm going to
tweak this and all everyone else is
going to think they actually discovered
something okay yeah yeah or I suppose
you did suppose you you're diabolical
you're just a prank oh I would do that
either uh you're just a prankster all
right
we have built-in protections against
that oh damn
we have another one they got a ring
camera we have an entire other ligo
in Washington oh making sure yes okay so
you would have to coordinate with
another prankster yeah to do it at the
exact moment okay whatever now
okay
they both made the measurement but
separated by a fraction of a second
just what you'd expect if the wave came
from One Direction continues to wash
over Earth and goes across and comes out
Seattle on the other side of the Earth
okay that 1500 miles whatever that
distance is takes like time to do that
they were able to measure that precisely
it was good so tell me about this so
let's talk about outer space for a
second yeah so I'm your guy yeah
who's in been in the seat but uh there
aren't that many astrophysicists out
there so you have you know if we did
have a guy who was a science man
recently and he was he uh well he he was
in charge of the cryonic freezing you
know those the there's a chronics
Institute where they freeze people on
the possibility that they bring them
back to life on the possibility that one
day they'll be able to bring him back to
life do you think that that's possible
or no I'm not con so I think what will
happen is we'll figure out
what ages us and we'll Nip Tuck fix that
and then who cares about the Frozen
people at that point we can all just
keep living oh I mean I don't right
right is it are we gonna need them
that's right that's what I'm saying I
don't know I you know uh people that
want to live forever in the life and
death chapter here I comment on that do
you really want to live forever it's a
whole thing
because if you live forever
what motivation do you have to do
anything today nothing nothing but
that's what I kind of like about
reincarnation
it's like when people are doing
reincarnation they're like I'll get to
it
you know when you believe in
reincarnation yeah but you you don't
know what you'll be reincarnated as and
so you could be recording as a roach or
an ant or something yeah it's hard to
fix a shelf as an ant
so that's a risk Risky Business there
but let me lay a little bit of
mathematical thinking on you okay
um for me there's nothing more
motivating
then the knowledge I'm going to die
um
think of the prisoner in the cell and
they're putting an X through every one
because every X is one day closer to
getting out
well let's do that for your life every X
you spend doing nothing that's a day you
could have done something and you're
gonna die one day yeah and it's there on
the calendar okay
this would so motivate me as it does
to be as productive as I can as helpful
as I can
Try to Make a Better World for your
privilege of having lived in it
so if knowing you're gonna die
brings meaning
to your life
then living forever
is a life of no meaning at all
damn
that's how I think about it
so no I don't I don't want to live
forever yeah I think if I got to if I
could live forever I'd probably go swim
more honestly or do something like you
know that I don't really love doing but
I kind of wish I did more that's a weird
that's a weird wish if I live forever I
would swim more even though I don't like
it who's what do you I'll give you
another chance answer that again
there was a lamest
no if I could live forever I would do
stuff I didn't really feel like doing
well yeah because it would be like you'd
have so much time you know I don't know
if I can live forever I don't know what
I would do that's a great question what
would you do if you could live forever
no I would say that is the sentence you
have to do it
I I I don't know
I
I don't know because so much of how I
organize my life is knowing I'm gonna
die right
and I have to think about and get back
to you on that okay I'll get back to you
on it too then fair and I hope it's not
I'll swim even though I don't like it
that's the lamest no no okay I'll try
and do better but I just that's how
that's what I think I would do I know
you are cleverer than that you're gonna
give me an answer that's better than me
do we what culture or ethnicity on Earth
say they're say aliens show up right is
there a society or culture or ethnicity
that's best evolved you think to handle
it scientists really
scientists
go ahead Theo if an alien landed right
in front of us and said to you Theo take
me to your leader are you going to take
him to the White House
no no of course not are you thinking to
Congress no no that's a great question
what's my point you would take him to
well I'm not going to speak for you but
I happen to be a scientist but if I were
not a scientist I would take him to a
scientist you would yes a biologist or a
a physicist somebody who's by the way
say science is closed that day
come back out to lunch come back
tomorrow open at nine in the morning so
you know even science has a sandwich bro
where would you take him you speak of
science like is the one dude behind the
counter
let me finish what happens if you're
trying to talk to him okay my point is
mathematics I give him a treat first I
think you'd have to treat they're not a
pet they just flew here in a it's ship
way more advanced than anything we've
ever conceived okay here here's a chew
toy
dude I'm just saying you gotta give them
a little you'll be the first human
Zapped by a alien laser oh at that point
you hit him with that Snicker dog then
your friend forever
Steven Spielberg where they're eating
what are they the the Reese's Pieces no
no oh yeah dude well he'd bring his
friends next week now you give a Reese's
to an alien it's gonna get diabetes how
do you know it can handle it it's just
so pretty
that's a good point bro now he's stuck
what if he becomes all lazy and stuff
when you start getting them acclimated
it's fat and lazy on Earth that has to
be a movie right you want to do a movie
like that I don't know but okay so he's
here what do you do what I'm saying is
that
I have a periodic table of elements that
are elements across the universe I know
mathematics that laws of physics that
apply Across the Universe they got here
from across the universe so those those
laws would be totally the same when
they're planning totally the same so if
you're going to start with a language
like oh this is a cup and this is a fork
and this is it's like this is our
elements and this is we call this
aluminum we call this and they will know
and they start to develop a common
vocabulary so that you can communicate
with them because they're not going to
speak English nor French nor Mandarin
none of the above that being said if
they send radio signals here the largest
radio telescope is going to pick it up
first and you know where that is hold on
let me think Arizona uh it was once in
on American soil in Puerto Rico the the
art of sibo telescope but that collapsed
out of disuse and okay the largest radio
telephone in the world is in China wow
so the first humans that will hear hear
the signal sent by aliens will be
Chinese astrophysicists
but we're talking about if they visit so
if they visit I'm saying bring them to a
scientist the scientist will know how to
think about and pose questions to them
for this for this reason and I got a
little dust up when I saw the movie
arrival
and Aliens visit and they Park these
pods floating over there and so the
government gets two people they get a a
linguist
and a physicist to decode their and I'm
thinking no no you get a cryptographer
and an astrobiologist that's what you
want to do I don't know if you saw the
movie the alien is like a septipod looks
like an octopus but it was only seven
things and it's squid inking messages on
a on a glass it's underwater or whatever
medium it's in and so oh there it goes
okay your boy brought it up on the on
the on the screen you got it right here
okay arrival yeah yeah yes arrival
diplomacy scene yeah so we're trying to
find out what are they trying to say to
us and why and so I would have brought a
cryptographer and uh and an
astrobiologist but they brought a was it
a linguist a cultural linguist and a not
an angle linguist um uh could you look
that up real quick the the profession of
the woman that
was she hot too I don't remember
because you got to bring a hottie out if
an alien shows I think you gotta show up
with some real diamonds yeah she was a
linguist linguish okay so so they have a
linguist and a physicist physicist is
good but not as good as a cryptographer
who's trying to figure out what the hell
they're saying so I posted that and I
shouldn't have uh that should have been
my forbidden Twitter file because no
because
with my people are in movies all the
time right we have astrophysicists all
how often is a linguist in a movie yeah
all right I always did one chance and I
felt bad I burned them I throw some
shade on there on there but now what
about this so tell me this if the
Chinese so the Chinese would be the
first people to know that right no no to
hear a signal okay that comes over do
you think that they would tell the rest
of us or not
uh probably not initially but uh but
eventually no no the thing is what what
should they they they built their own
damn telescope that telescope is a mile
in circumference by the way you want to
get a sense of how big it is it's called
the fast telescope 500 meter aperture
spherical telescope acronym fast but if
they know and they don't tell us man
but then they get to they can they
can have a horse and they say we are the
chosen ones and everyone else on Earth
isn't uh send your ray beams to you know
I don't know what they're gonna do
um but there it is uh we have another
image
oh we are we're looking at the image on
the screen I was there I visited there
we filmed there for Cosmos what oh my
gosh bro you gotta hold on to that
footage oh my gosh we gotta make this
why are we why don't we have anything
like that because we are not we'd like
to think of ourselves we're Americans
and we're lead we're we are we over
history we've been reactive
to challenges from other countries not
proactive and what are we now as far as
when it comes to challenges from outer
space we have nothing that Rivals that
wow at all
so when it comes to space we're not
really the number one no no in in space
in access to space plus you have the
billionaires boys race that's up there
you know and by the way there's a whole
chapter in here called Earth and Moon
where I just talk about the relationship
between Earth and the moon and going to
the Moon how we went to the moon to
explore the Moon and we looked over our
shoulder
and we discovered Earth for the first
time
and it changed us between 1968 and 1972
do you know what happened well we saw
the picture of earthrise over the moon
and I claimed that there was a firmware
upgrade to our awareness in this
universe because what happened
immediately
by 1970 we founded the Environmental
Protection Agency the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration that
monitors climate and weather we had the
comprehensive Clean Air Act Clean Water
Act we banned leaded gas we banned DDT
the first Earth day was 1970. birthday
was pretty chill okay it's chill yeah
but if you ask any of them why you have
Earth Day now well because it's the
right thing to do this is the firmware
upgrade they're not thinking space right
they're just thinking obvious we should
no you know what else was going on in
1970 we were at War Hot War Cold War
campus unrest civil rights movement in
1968 two leaders were assassinated 1971
was it was the shootings on Kent State
campus we had issues here on Earth don't
tell me oh it felt like the right time
to protect Earth we had other issues
something else was operating in your
brain stem that you weren't even aware
of that's the that's the firmware
upgrade do you remember
you would have seen videos of it the
crying Indian yeah okay people throw
trash out the window and he turns around
any tears and he's in headdress of
course that dude was was Italian who's
an Italian actor yeah he was Italian
Italian Heritage so so back then you can
do that right right you could do that
back then but my point is when did that
public service announcement come 1970
. people were people throwing trash out
their window for decades so something at
that point upgrade made us think we got
to start looking at this place that
we're on you know what that's called a
cosmic perspective
now what about this do you think we are
due for other firmware upgrades I would
like to think so a former upgrade where
we stopped killing each other yeah you
think you know there's no greater
argument someone gives for killing
someone else
than what they believe in rather than
what is actually true
it's almost like the less evidence you
have for something
the more you're willing to give your own
life or to take someone's else's life
for it and that's some weird stuff for
our species weird Behavior pattern for
now the world is a much safer place than
ever before
here's a number to sleep on you ready
yeah
probably we live in a time where if a
bus drives into a crowd of protesters
kills 10 people
that's world headlines
for a day
it's National headlines
for a week it's local headlines for a
month
okay kills 10 people
between 1939 and 1945.
1 000 humans
were killed per hour
of every hour between 1939 and 1945.
that doesn't happen today when yes we
have War we have conflict people are
dying it's not like that not like that
it is not like that
and not long before that there was
another world war
plus a pandemic on top of it that
ultimately killed more people than the
world war did
so less people are dying yes we have
more people and fewer people are dying
and fewer people are living in poverty
than ever before okay and
so
yeah so we have about eight billion
people in the world uh we'll level off
at 10 billion there are very good
reasons to think that that it won't go
above 10 billion it's not it's not going
to keep growing yeah because people
aren't having as many children they're
not having as many children we're living
longer so that mitigates that but then
not having as many children and the
developed worlds developing worlds that
used to have the most babies the women
are getting educated and educated women
have fewer children
yeah
it's true man they was just running is
that how you say that I didn't know that
was a way to say that that's a new way I
never thought of saying it
man this black hole is close
no more kids when the day you'd have
many take that thing you have many kids
because kids would kids would die right
you didn't you want to run the farm or
whatever you're doing right so now they
don't die we keep them alive and so you
the so the birth rates are dropping uh
even in the developing companies and in
some countries the birth rate is below
replacement level so this all averages
out and you will settle out at about 10
billion
but what my point is
we live in sort of safer times than ever
before even if it doesn't feel that way
interesting you were talking about
feeling before uh was it Gallop or or
one of the polling agencies for the last
30 years they've asked people
is your community and yours is it are
you safer this year than you were last
year no it's more dangerous it's fear
for 27 out of 30 years people have said
it's more dangerous than the previous
year
and in
those years the crime rate has dropped
precipitously the entire time so they're
slang in fear
that's what sells Evening News really
does evening news and I have a I have an
example on this when I grew up
every night I grew up in New York City
every night the Evening News would lead
off with a fire
in some home
usually it's a space heater there's a
little space heaters no back then people
smoked in bed okay okay and it was
before that's great and it was before
that's fun to do but smoke alarms yeah
okay and by the way I got something
funny for you I'll just tell you just in
a quick minute but the point is
I was certain I would die in a fire dang
I would never live to adulthood because
I saw that every single day
and so now there are fewer fires because
we have some there's a few and they make
big news but the rate compared back then
New York has fewer firehouses we've been
closing firehouses people just don't
need them but it's more boring though
and by the way what really saved things
are smoke detectors because I'm old
enough to remember you might be a little
too young for this where before smoke
detectors you had to buy flame retardant
things in your home your curtains were
flame [ __ ] you're you you're your
child had flame retardant onesies yeah
really okay and but if you think that
through
if they're in the crib and the flame is
strong enough
it's not going to help to burn their
onesies you don't want the onesies to
ignite your kid is dead oh yeah long
dead it's almost like when you get the
hash brown but it's in that little thing
you know
I don't know if it's exactly like that
but I know I know exactly what you're
talking about
where's the potato if the whole thing is
brown is hash brown okay yeah I don't
know if I need this little holster for
like I just you know okay so so uh so my
my point is this flame and we later
learned some of them cause cancer that's
not what kept people alive ultimately
it's the smoke it's the smoke detector
wow um but where was I going with that I
was at some bigger point I was making
well I think things like that take the
fun out of everything you know they used
to have these um you know what you're
talking about crime rates so everyone
thought the crime rate was going up it's
been going down the whole time your
perception is not reality oh yeah and
that's a lot of what this book is but
the whole the whole book is that
um
oh I remember we had these underwears
that had a buzzer in them right because
I wet the bed right so I was probably
probably late 20s and we had these
underwear when I was a child that got a
buzzer right in the car I didn't know
that yeah so the P would would he liquid
hit it they'd go off and you'd wake up
and you'd go to the bathroom yeah didn't
know they had that I mean it was
interesting it helped I mean it was
embarrassing because you hit like a lot
of people with the buzzer was right
right like are the cops coming
did it work is something in the oven
it'd be like 4am you'd tell your friends
like I think something's in the oven
yeah sleepovers are awkward right so
does it did it work for you it worked
pretty good I think and then a pill came
out and that really yeah I think the
pill was it yeah I mean that shut me off
Better Living Through Chemistry we are
sacks of chemicals yeah and the evidence
of that is you ever seen the book of
medicines to treat your ailments it's
all chemicals yeah I'm just saying we're
sacks of chemicals yeah that's what
helped uh so you went to bed until your
20s oh yeah that's late dude oh I was
late you gotta set up a hose or
something oh dude my whole life I'm in a
late bloomer wait so in your not to get
all TMI here but uh when you were peeing
in the bed were you dreaming that you
were peeing in a bathroom sometimes I
would be dreaming that I was peeing
sometimes I would even be dreaming that
I was peeing in a bed
you know it was like my brain couldn't
get well that's an authentic reality
couldn't give me any more clues okay but
sometimes yeah I would just be just deep
asleep I don't know but yeah I just I
just wet the bed man I wet it as a child
and I wedded as an adult
um you turned out okay though yeah I
think I'm just a late bloomer man
everything has been about 10 years okay
really your first one you know you're
okay with that
um why does it feel sometimes when I
look at outer when I look at space right
I'm standing there I'm looking out at
Space by the way if you're in space and
your jet pack stopped working if you pee
forward you'll you'll move backwards
that much propulsion will help well in
space any propulsion works because
there's no friction anywhere so if you
send any liquid out for you could fart
the other direction and it'll Propel
backwards so don't pee and fart at the
same time no no no you lose your your
net momentum yeah you just stay there so
choose are you gonna fart or you're
gonna pee okay and we're good right damn
I wasted all my fuel you're just sitting
there
um what if um no that's advice I'm
pretty sure you didn't think you'd be
getting today I didn't at all right but
I'm glad to know that take a can of
beans if you're headed out
um by the way you know the swamis that
they always show pictures of who are
levitated yeah with their cross legs
um
so you can't do that unless he is
actively expelling gas out of his
butthole okay so you'd have to like eat
a lot of beans and sew up the butthole
to get very high pressure damn and then
pop it open and then he can levitate wow
yeah so there yeah so that's that's
definitely advertising then they're
using that they're obviously well no
I'll say completely defying known laws
of physics so nobody can really levitate
like that no one has ever done that in a
controlled laboratory okay so if they
can do it there's some magic that they
do
and okay it's just not useful if I can't
reproduce it in the lab uh under control
conditions with cameras and everything
it's just not useful yeah and it's so
magic isn't real
um
no well you know the Arthur C Clarke
edict any sufficiently advanced
science uh-huh is indistinguishable from
Magic hmm that's a good one okay
so if an alien comes up and and waves
their hand and something happens you'll
say It's Magic but to them it's science
it's just super science correct if in
fact I I tell you I don't mean to brag
or anything you do magic no I did when I
was a kid actually I can see that I did
physics magic I'd pull the the the
tablecloth out from under I still do
that it's fun yeah yeah
I have large hands so I can Palm a card
pretty easily
um so so I did that as a kid I made
money at kids birthday parties I think I
was 12 or something wow doing it for
six-year-olds what was your first job
oh I was a camp counselor and I worked
whole summer and I made 150 for YMCA uh
it was a version of that yes it was it
was some other thing but it was through
through a church thing yeah yeah I went
to YMCA Camp it was fun yeah yeah and
then I went to well before then I went
to Camp I was in a YMCA Camp several
years in a row Camp was fun no it's good
it was good it was good so but but let
me tell you the job I hated the most
just just the whole Optics of it I got
to college
and I'm on a work study program but the
the work part was like whatever job you
can get that and that was contributed to
your tuition yeah same I had to be in
the bookstore well no now fine if it was
a bookstore but not the job I got okay I
cleaned the bathrooms
in the dorms of other students
probably just all semen in there
I mean not you know
so I'm just saying just the just the out
of my cleaning bathrooms you know but
I'm doing it for fellow students who I'm
I'm gonna see in my physics class or in
my art class right and it was it was
just
I did it but I just thought they need a
different way to work this out yeah okay
and so
um yeah but it puts you through college
and you get through college and that was
that you earned your stripes man I'll
say you went through I mean you but but
you know what I regret I've never had a
job where I had to tolerate the behavior
of someone else like a checkout grounder
or a server at a restaurant or a flight
attendant I've never had to
tolerate someone being a complete
[ __ ] and smile while you're doing it
because corporate policy says the
customer is always right I've never had
to do that oh that's everybody at a CVS
now I feel like they have to put up with
everything now yeah so that's
interesting I try to be empathetic even
though I've never recognized that yeah
oh my gosh is that it usually it's kind
of an important job to have yeah
um is outer space like is outer space
gay or straight
uh so there's an entire chapter here
called
gender and identity
okay uh-huh I'm just putting it out
there okay General it's an entire
chapter what that looks like through a
scientific lens and what I will tell you
is
oh yeah I remember you talking about the
facial structures okay so I'm gonna give
you an answer are you ready yeah is
outer space gay or straight
every practically everything we see and
measure in space
not only objects but temperature size
density
is on a spectrum
so for you to say is the universe gay or
straight
I'm going to tell you whatever the
universe is it's on a spectrum
okay in fact the very word spectrum
comes from what happens when you take
light and break it up into its colors we
just happen to assign names to the seven
colors
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet but it's an it's a continuum
we're just being lazy by assigning seven
colors our brain doesn't want to see
nuance
because it's easier for us to think in
binary so it's are you with me or are
you against me well maybe you're
somewhere in between are you a boy are
you a girl maybe they're expressing
themselves somewhere in between and your
brain has a difficult time
recognizing a spectrum and so you're
requiring it be into a bin so there you
are
forcing other people to match how you
see the world and that's wrong
that's no I'm not let me not say it's
wrong I'm gonna say
um The World Is Not Gonna Change to fit
your inability to recognize how it's
actually manifesting it's not going to
do that
so so it's by
no it's on a continuum
so whatever it is you can say is is is
the universe sweet or salty is the
universe whatever it is you're asking me
is it this or is it that Ah that's the
binary brain trying to force a Continuum
into two categories so it's like Chex
Mix
except with more objects more kinds of
objects than what you find in check
checks mix has like five things in it
yeah that's true okay imagine if Chex
Mix had everything damn in a Continuum
and it kept changing now look at how our
brain works we have hurricane strengths
right oh yeah they measure this wind
speed
do you realize it's a continuum
but we we divided it into five
categories right but it's a Continuum do
you realize you can go from low category
three to high category three and it's
and they'll just talk about uh Irma is
still a category three one mile an hour
faster
and it's category four it's breaking
news oh yeah hurricane Irma is now
category four yeah excuse me it's one
mile an hour faster than it was
yesterday yeah people lie to say the
wind's broken okay so I'm just on the
winds making a bowl of cereal some guy
said that's funny that's funny so my
point is even with hurricane speed
strengths we force them into categories
when it's actually a container I see so
it's a Continuum out there so so because
it looks kind of gay I feel like but
then sometimes it does things that seem
really straight but those are also my
definitions of those correct you're
forcing the universe into your two
categories right I think what's tough I
think for people just in layman's terms
is when you have a template of society
over time and the and things start to
come in and make it evolve or adjust
it's hard sometimes to get those things
all the way to the Grassroots level I
would claim that the template was always
people forcing a natural variation into
categories ah do you know Joan of Arc
you remember she was remember you read
she was burned at the stake yeah yeah
1400 was she doing witchery okay well
okay that would be one way you would
burn people at the stake but uh uh they
couldn't burn her at the stake for not
being religious she was very religious
she was trying to kick the British out
of France her mother country she led
soldiers into battle wow do you know
half I don't know it was half precisely
but a big reason why they indicted her
and burned her at the stake was for
cross-dressing damn
and I thought okay there's a there's a
passage in the Bible in Deuteronomy you
ready it's if a woman Don the clan the
clothes this is very close to precise if
the woman does the clothes of a man
she is an Abomination unto the Lord thy
God oh man and so they said we can get
her on that they're like looking trying
to throw the book at her right we got
her on this because you can't lead
soldiers into battle with a skirt riding
side saddle yeah that does not work no
you got to put on at least a strong hat
at the Earth so is she an early person
who's just a tomboy who's expressing
herself and male though she's
biologically female oh she'd have been
in A League of Their Own probably okay
so we know yeah grown up
in classes where there was the Tomboy
girl and the slightly effeminate boy we
we if not ourselves this has been with
us forever yeah it's in literature and
it's in the thing and the difference
between then and now is we have a a
raised social Consciousness so that
those folks
on the Continuum are are less so the
object of mockery
in storytelling they're just other
characters now and there's still more
room to improve that but I'm saying
um you have people who are trans people
who are who are uh all full up trans or
just simply wearing clothes they're the
not what you want them to wear based on
what you think they should be yeah is
that a free country if this is what what
concerns me a bit a lot of the
resistance to this comes from the
conservative side of the voting public
and they're trying to control the
freedoms of people's expressing
themselves in some way I read
so that the pursuit of happiness did we
read this somewhere in the founding
documents of and if my Pursuit of
Happiness is wearing a skirt and putting
on makeup and lipstick no matter whether
or not I have a penis
um
you want to take that away from me
why
that is it in a way that's a violation
of what it means to live in a free
country yeah I think people just accuse
you of gayen or whatever they accuse you
of like queering the fact that it would
be an accusation at all rather than a
recognition that there are people
different from you who live in this free
country well look I'll tell you this a
lot of times I've been around a lot of
Dr like sometimes there's a lot of drunk
man you know and I don't drink but I'll
get around them sometimes and you could
see they start wanting uh you know they
start you know their lips get a little
wet and you see them wanting to be you
know
so I think you know if we were honest
with ourselves it wouldn't even be a
problem if we were honest with it
centuries ago well yeah there's probably
just old and also some of it is
templates some of it is tradition and
people want to like people worry I think
it's too much if you lose TR like and
I'm not saying they're correct
Traditions but I think a lot of people
worry if you lose tradition then what
does that mean I think you know I think
we're still evolving in a way that we
want to look at at existence in a larger
scale and not just in the scope of our
own life I'm a big fan of traditions and
let's call them rituals for the moment
okay a Thanksgiving dinner is a ritual
the traditions and rituals in and of
themselves I greatly value them they
become they're some of the greatest
uh binding forces in a culture are
Traditions yeah okay in Passover the Jew
the the observant Jews of the world are
all doing the same thing
basically at the same time relative to
the sunset okay and so
that's a binding Force but if your
tradition is not the celebration but
what you look like what you sound like
what you say how what you think then
that's those are Traditions trying to
remove freedoms that your country might
otherwise be giving you yeah and so they
come from Traditions yeah they kept
tribes together oh my gosh where does
the other stuff come from like yeah like
where does it but I think it maybe it
feels like I'm trying to decide what
that feels like to people that makes
them
so commonly that those are things that
are hung onto you know uh well if they
it's one thing because you have your own
ritual okay I used to always have
candles for dinner okay I I blow through
yards of candles it's a romantic and I'd
like a bottle of wine and with my wife
no no I and so but so for me that was a
little bit Rich when my mother burn
candles and she was Catholic and candles
are a thing in a Catholic Church oh yeah
yeah so I and the candles are burning
during the mass so I a little bit of
candle worked into me but I'm not that's
nice I'm not forcing someone to do
something with the candle right okay I'm
not forcing someone else to pray to the
candle I'm not trying to change the
behavior of someone else it's just
something I do and I do it all right
it's when you cross over and require
other people recognize this yeah
um or or you require other people
abandon it just because you don't want
it that's not a free country that's all
I'm saying you can imagine a country
where everyone's homogenized in whatever
way you want
those countries exist I didn't think
that was America yeah I didn't say that
right I didn't think that was Merck I
think it was America well it's just it's
really it's I spent six years in Texas
I've met my wife in Texas oh but Austin
Texas UT Austin
are you a Texas Fan uh so the funny
thing be honest I don't know if I
haven't told anybody this uh so I'm a
New Yorker in Texas which was a little
bit mind-blowing you know just the
Confederate flag is everywhere and the
gun the gun rack on the back of the
pickup yeah and it's just a really I I
was I was almost anthropological for me
to observe the Texas tribe that's what I
was thinking what does anthropological
mean it means I'm I'm I don't know that
I'll ever assimilate but this is
something interesting to observe and
take notes on okay okay I'd be an
anthropologist okay guys studying the
culture okay so I did that and were you
really wearing that hat really and those
boots like really and this is a woman
you're talking
and your belt buckle is that big really
and so it's all weird but again I'm
recognizing it's another place right I
don't want to homogenize him to be New
Yorkers this is Texas a good point just
got his own history Six Flags Over Texas
yeah okay it's sick Texas with six
different countries all right I don't
know anybody else that can say that you
know the six countries right Mexico uh
Spain I think France uh the Confederacy
the United States itself and the
Republic of Texas oh damn what did I did
I leave one out or count one twice but
that's where you get Six Flags the the
the amusement park you didn't know this
dude you didn't know that finally some
stats I can use oh my gosh finally some
information I can use it that's how you
get Six Flags if the kid didn't come out
of nowhere yeah I didn't know I never
thought you go into the state capitol
and you see the flags yeah I've actually
been in state capital right there yeah
but um so I'm there and I and no so
here's what happened
when I left Texas it was six years later
I I get back to New York and say you
know
I want to wear some of those boots
so the next time I visited I picked up
some boots yeah and then I you know I
kind of liked that hat not the full up
you know seven inch brand but the
smaller brand so I own
six cowboy hats five pairs of boots and
one of them is like ostrich you know I
guess a stretch they get out digging out
the animals I don't have the lizard or
whatever that one is the no the
alligator I don't have the alligator but
uh so I got some stretch at the house
dude I wear that on Fifth Avenue I'll do
that yeah and so it people it turns
heads but I'm comfortable in that
because I I felt it it took it was a
time delay yeah right it was I feel it
now and now I can appreciate a Texas
movie or Texas culture Texas Music which
is not it's not country western really
uh it's not it's not it's not Nashville
I should say no it's not it's it's a lot
more it's a lot more like red clay kind
of yeah yeah
um and I didn't know a sad song Until I
heard a sad Texas song I mean yeah I'm a
big fan of the Blues you know Blues all
up the coast you know the Mississippi on
up to Chicago Blues but up the river I
guess I should say but
um Texas you know up some singing and uh
you know in my dog oh this is sadness
sadness okay Parker McCollum you gotta
listen to him he's kind of a sad
I'm a blues guy I'll do it he's yeah you
know what his is a little bit of Blues
in a way
um so you know I often theorize we talk
about a lot of this show like beige the
future is all going to be based like
eventually everything's kind of merging
we mean skin color yeah that eventually
everything is just kind of merging
um and I wonder if it'll be like that
with sexuality as well that everything
will just will everyone be like kind of
this beige trans kind of like you know
uh gang bang you know or like everybody
just like
you know will everybody just be like a
beige trans graffiti artist that's what
I feel like I feel like we're all just
kind of because I think there are enough
people in the world that value
individual out individuality that we
will never be so homogenized really yeah
that's what I think
uh so let's take this to a a scientific
limit okay we cannot control the genome
what is that uh you know so I got your
genes and I can see you in in the uterus
and I can nip and Tuck and snip and
think and you'll come out uh six feet
tall uh with this color skin this gender
with this thing and this that and I can
make you and that's not outlawed
we don't the the ethics of this we don't
know how to do that yet but I don't see
why we'll net that wouldn't one day
happen our ethics are not really quite
keeping up with it not from what I've
read yet but there are people thinking
about it okay the first thing we're
going to do is cure diseases for sure
all right you know genetic right you'll
go in and stop people from having
different kind of down syndrome right
exactly exactly exactly so obvious ones
and we all have to agree which what to
cure because even that has ethical
issues that's true for example it was
not until 1987 I report on that here in
the gender and
um Express gender and identity chapter
not until 1987 where the American
Psychological Society Psychiatric
association whatever their acronym is
um the the American Association of
psychiatrists it wasn't until 1987 where
they removed
homosexuality from the Encyclopedia of
mental disorders oh it used to be in
there yes
so you asked the question it was before
1987 or even earlier and you had the
medical capacity to quote fix someone
whose genetic profile if that's where
it's found it makes them gay would you
do that
back then they probably would because
that's a disorder they thought it was a
mental distance and then you find out
that at least 15 of the one out of six
is this at what point is it a disorder
and what point is it's just the natural
variation of who we are as a species
damn that's crazy so the guy who's
writing the disorders obviously was a
straight guy
ah
perceptive right on and and there's the
guy what's his neuroscientist I always
forget his name but I guess if you're
super straight say you're super straight
you wandering out of a cave or whatever
right you're a straight guy you see him
I know that I'm straight can I tell you
how I know I'm straight how I know I'm
straight because
I wrestled for eight years
the muscled sinewy sweaty bodies of
other men yeah and at no time did I even
have a tingle in my body it's like I'm
gonna pin your ass to the mat and get up
and walk away okay that's what I'm good
I was Captain of my high school's
wrestling team I'm just thinking my
hands are all over men's bodies if I had
any urge I would have felt it then so if
they do one two three four and you still
have to tapping out the longer you stay
there oh it's counting the thing but I
think yeah you just stay there and don't
tap because it feels good I think that's
crazy baby yeah so so so I'm I'm just
gender heterosexual do you ever wonder
if you could ever but because some
people think you could evolve into it
like I you know I wouldn't like I I
would wonder if one day I could be when
I'm 70 years old be a homosexual you
know I don't I don't know all the
drivers and causes and what's genetic
and what's cultural I I don't know I
don't even care it's just whatever
people want to be in a free country let
them be that yeah right so to even argue
it it's like that's like arguing should
someone wear their hair one way or the
other where the part it's it's how you
express but I wouldn't say I'm a
straight guy you got your moment and
you're rocking that you've been rocking
the mullet from day one that's your
thing if you came out with an afro
you're somebody else at that point yeah
but this country allows that I don't
know if your fans would allow it but the
country would allow it like okay
what about this so I think yeah I could
see if you're a straight guy you're
writing the book right on what is yeah a
straight psychiatrist right right in the
book you see a guy you know you're
hanging out with your buddies one of
them reaches for another guy's wiener or
whatever I could see you being like oh
this is uh this is but do you think he
thought it was wrong or he just thought
just it simply I don't know that they
value judge they're just saying it's a
disorder right the need of repair so but
it was a disorder based on that things
are just supposed to be this way because
they had whatever biases they had
whatever
inability to embrace the spectrum of
humanity presented to him right does
nature is nature just or does nature gay
also oh okay uh their books on this the
I forget rainbows
can we look this up real quick rainbows
uh just look at Rainbow and sex and
there's a book that'll come up uh just
real quick
uh Evolutions rainbow okay so so there's
a book called Evolution's rainbow okay
which explores what species out there
actually have full spectrum sex okay gay
sex bang sex there's some there's rape
in some there's Dolphins there's some
there's no other way to understand it
unless okay so there's a full range of
what's and I don't care if there's a
line called or
so here's my point
that I don't know that we should care
what the rest of the animal kingdom is
doing do you know there's a there's a
mole rat that's called this this comes
in a mole rat where one variant on it
they mate for life and the other one
there is promiscuous as go all get out
damn and they're both mole rats I got
both varians so they're both they're
both mole rats so and then people say oh
Eagles mate forever and they want that
to be we want to emulate that and then
you find out that Bonner boat chimps
they're [ __ ] all the time oh to
resolve differences to to fight each
just look at this video yeah it's behind
the wall gotta go behind the wall on the
video and so and but also very close to
us genetically my point is we're human I
don't care what the other animals are
doing you can find an animal that'll
support or or deny whatever claim you're
trying to make about us so forget them
we're our own species yeah and that's
true we have the capacity to Grant
freedoms in some governments to your
to support your happiness we value that
yeah that's cool because it's crazy to
think that some countries don't right
that's why I'm glad I'm in America yeah
am I good at that right am I getting
like a B plus
um what about this so
um so do you think we'll ever really be
able to travel like into another galaxy
like interstellarly do you think you
need you need a wormhole we're not doing
that without Wormhole we don't have like
diesel or whatever we don't have
anything that'll push us there is no
rocket no there's a rocket that would
get there eventually like in a few
million years but you don't live that
long yeah we we have Rockets powerful
enough to get you around the solar
system in your lifetime but to the
nearest stars at those speeds it would
take 50 000 years
that's why they're talking about
generational ships where you go you have
babies no they grow up they have babies
so people it's called a generational
ship wow it's a little weird because
it's
a little weird because you're we're
we're obligating The Unborn
to continue a mission that you're
starting that they didn't have freedom
to reject
that's an ethical thing right there
I don't know are you for it
I'm just waiting around for the Wormhole
just say yeah dude
let's sit in the boat okay come on
um so so yeah so then we don't have
anything right now that'll ever get us
so we are almost kind of stranded here
stranded in the solar system it's not so
bad a lot of good stuff going no it's
cool yeah yeah why is it when I um when
I look up at the like the sky by the way
just to be clear we got to the Moon
hung out on the moon and came back in
less time than it took Columbus to cross
the Atlantic wow
so we're doing all right you know I'm
okay I'm okay we get to Mars when I'm 10
people but we can send Hardware to Mars
in nine months a little less that's good
the Wormhole what would it how big would
it be would you have to would you be
able to walk into it or you have to kind
of step into it I I we okay no it's like
let me step across it like as a
threshold yeah you've seen uh Marvel and
and doctor strange or uh Rick and Morty
these are these are literal they call
them portals to other dimensions
whatever but a wormhole would just be
that you would just go through on one
side come out the other and you would
not see the fabric of the Wormhole it
would just be a hole in space and it's a
whole every direction you look at when
we think of a hole in a floor and you
fall through this is a hole in full
three-dimensional space no matter which
direction you go in you're entering the
hole and you'll come out in another
place
and uh in some places if you take space
time and curve it in one of the
illustrations we have up on the wall now
it's curved so if you were to travel
that whole distance around there because
that could take you a long time you bend
this it imagine it's a piece of paper
you bend it cut a hole through the two
edges you didn't have to take that long
route and you bypass it and you get to
the other side of the Galaxy before the
end of the TV commercial and that's how
the warp drive people do it is that
mathematically possible yes really you
promise oh yes on paper we can do that
but you need some matter that can that's
the opposite of gravity so it's negative
energy stuff are we building that can
pry open I'm not authorized to say if
we're building that
are you really not yeah I'm just kidding
oh
plus that's what I would say if I wasn't
authorized I'm just kidding that's
exactly what I would say uh that's like
asking someone if you're a spy yeah say
no I'm not a spy that's what a spider
says you know there's no way out of that
one you know dang man no no so so what
we could you take stuff with you or
would you have to not have any like
carry-ons or whatever like how would you
do you remember Terminator when he came
through time he had to come through
naked okay oh yeah because uh clothing
couldn't go through the the the portal
uh or only living tissue could go
through the portal but here's a problem
that I think they forgot or they hair is
not alive
so you're going through balls she should
have gone through complete bald ass
bare-ass ball plus he has living tissue
but it's on top of his metallic skeleton
oh yeah so so the skeletons shouldn't
have made it through
he would have just been a pile of Flesh
or along the ground they weren't
entirely consistent with their own rules
would you be brave enough to go if they
offered it to go no I'd send a gerbil
first true first I'm not going through
first damn bro people ask me do you want
to ride on elon's rocket and say only
after he sends his mother yeah brings
her back safely then I'll go yeah until
then I'm sitting right here wow
yeah you wouldn't go huh until I know
it's safe all right two gerbils go then
they come back and they're not weird or
anything
when I'm doing the uh the hamster wheels
we're doing the hamster dance right
right Smooth Criminal
on the wheel yeah yeah
so
um
did he do that in Smooth Criminal maybe
he might have I think it was
yeah but he did a lien on it yeah yeah
it was the first concert you ever went
to oh thanks for asking uh I don't go to
many concerts for for
not Noble reasons one of them is I
prefer the quality of a studio album to
people screaming in the background oh
yeah the occasional song is good like
like free bird live that's the only way
I'm consuming that song because it it's
longer than the album it's like three
minutes longer or something and Leonard
Skynyrd is jamming and every of the
instruments so occasionally you get the
extra stuff going on in the life but
mostly I like the acoustic quality of
Studio albums so therefore I'm not going
to see you in concert I'm going to buy
your album and just listen to you at
home okay that's one two
concerts are too expensive dude I'd have
that money growing up it's expensive so
I just didn't go and plus I didn't have
a car because I grew up in the city so
concerts were not just when you're in
the city it's less of a thing most of
the people went to concerts in Madison
Square Garden where out of town or it's
coming in from Jersey and Long Island
and things so but I think my very first
concert was Earth Wind and Fire oh yeah
I saw them in Austin Texas and then I
saw uh The Commodores Oh yeah then my
sister worked for PepsiCo which had
retained Michael Jackson for things and
I saw Michael Jackson pretty good seats
too in Madison Square Garden no way so
these are some good stuff I'm not yeah
that's good uh how was that that was
good he did stuff white all the way back
from ABC it was a full retrospective
wow yeah it was a full retrospective and
so I saw him uh I saw Simon and
Garfunkel but my favorite it's like my
they're my my people let us Fila is that
them no that's the Beatles huh right so
we're saying that again got some real
estate here in my oh yeah that's him
yeah yeah that's him that's one of the
songs yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and so just a a balladeer is that a
word a balladeer of the era yeah uh
Simon and Paul Simon and and or
Garfunkel and a couple of other concerts
oh oh this one was good I saw the 50th
anniversary concert of the who oh my
gosh and and you know who open for him
Joan Jett
oh oh
that's good that was good was it good oh
man and I I I recorded I know I was
allowed to do this but I recorded Roger
Daltrey singing the line
because he's 70 now singing like I hope
I die before I'm old that was his lyric
right his dude's lyrics that's uh
research yeah that was told I was
totally I was at dinner the other night
I went to dinner the other night with
David Spade actually we were both doing
shows somewhere in San Diego cool and
I'm name dropping there but he's my
friend and we had and anyway Roger
Daughtry came and he sat at the table
next to us oh and he and David knew each
other so I just got to watch them talk
to each other for a second very cool so
that to me was pretty cool cool yeah um
God you know I do cities too do you know
that you go perform yeah oh and speak
yeah and just answer questions and and
and and they're in theaters dude yeah I
believe that right and and the numbers
that they get for stand-up comedians
they because we're not Broadway right
we're not you know you're you're a
one-person show on the stage right with
very little overhead to produce your
show right and so that's the same with
me whether it's a screen and I show the
universe but uh I always interesting to
see what comedians came before me or
after me because I'm a big fan of your
trade uh so thanks yeah I think a lot of
guys obviously well it's interesting
thing about Joe Rogan is he introduces
people to a lot of other people that
they may not have been introduced from
his audience yeah audience base it's
pretty fascinating yeah yeah I mean he's
done it all he's the stand up and the TV
host and everything yeah yeah and he
just is so cute he is one of the most
curious people I've ever met in my life
he's a consummate researcher that's an
example of it and the difference is he's
curious in the moment and he's got an
expert and he fills it up and then the
expert goes away and then he fills in
the blanks with his own thoughts yeah so
so if you want to do that right you have
the Curiosity your guest stimulates that
curious curiosity and then you go take
out books and finish the gaps yeah you
know look at the documentaries and then
your your curiosity isn't just
satisfied in the moment it's something
that goes beyond the moment so that you
get the broader deeper understanding of
what's going on that would have helped
him when he got that dust up with the
vaccines yeah oh yeah they got on to him
huh yeah yeah totally got on them and
people pulling out of Stitcher and
things you know was it Stitcher or
SoundHound I forget what what whatever
is his Spotify sorry
um yeah and people are pulling out of
Spotify you know out of solidarity so I
it's so he got in his dust up it's
because he's curious in the moment but
in an add sort of way right right
because the next the next shiny object
he wants to know about that right and
then he gets he knows just enough about
that and you get into uh into that zone
yeah where you know just enough
to think you're right
but not enough to know you're wrong hmm
that's a zone that many people get into
yeah I think a lot I I from what I
remember and I don't know all of it I
think a lot of his stuff was that the
the bio the the bio companies were
really pushing the vaccines on people a
ton
you know there'll be yeah but is that a
reason to not
protect yourself against covet what you
have to do is yeah some of that can
happen all right I don't know how much
it happened during covet but we're
honest with ourselves about profit
motives right yeah so now you watch now
you look at
who's dying in the hospitals okay
it's
people
who are unvaccinated
with comorbidities primarily and then
other people who are sort of
unvaccinated and older who were just
sort of at risk but not being old is not
as self a comorbidity like being right
but it is but right these are factors
they're people who were not getting
vaccinated
and so do you want to stay out of the
hospital do you want to not die and you
look at the death toll the excess death
because of kovid
um it is a you can see the bump in the
in the in the
um mortality Statistics over those two
years there's there's whatever it is
that's level because with the same
amount of approximately same amount of
people number of people die every year
in the United States and then in 2020 it
went up
and then when the vaccine came in you
saw it coming down a little and then the
people so yes it's a free country but
you can catch it and then spread it to
somebody else who needs the protection
or can't get vaccinated because they
have an immune problem do you so at that
level you're being selfish that's all do
you think in hindsight that I always
felt like herd immunity would have been
the best thing for that I don't I'm not
a scientist yeah sure but here at
immunity it depends on The lethality of
the drug and how quickly it spreads
that'll determine the exact herd
immunity but you got to typically be up
around 90 vaccination so that 10 would
not have to be vaccinated and they won't
catch it but the herd immunity in a
rational
society that cares about its citizens
the nine percent ten percent that don't
get immunized it's because they can't
be immunized
do you want the herd immunity to protect
the weak
the people who are immune compromised
the people who have some genetic
disorder where they rely on you to be
vaccinated so I don't catch so they
don't catch the disease that's how we
should be using herd immunity not
because you're because you're
um by the way the Liberals and
conservatives met each other on the
other side of the fence for this
the OG anti-vaxxers we're liberals okay
who don't trust the Pharma and don't
trust the big business and all the rest
of this and then the the the freedom
angle came in from the right uh you
can't you can't I don't want to yeah
okay don't put this in my body right
right it's dangerous vaccines are
dangerous that vaccines cause or yeah so
they cherry-picked things and they go to
websites and they spend you know an hour
or more but researching it and then
there will claim to know more than the
medical professionals so sure if you if
you don't want to be get vaccinated go
live alone until the till the virus goes
away but stay out of the zones of people
who could catch it from you if you
caught it do you feel like if we would
have not done a vaccine and just let the
virus go through us it would have just
went through us it would have killed
five times as many people really easily
easily
wow you don't remember hospitals were
overrun people were in the corridors
they have mass burials oh my gosh how
quickly people forget well I remember
they put people on ventilators but
didn't then then they realized that they
shouldn't have put people well yeah so
on the moving Frontier of a new thing
yeah it's easy to sell you shouldn't
have done that right right no at the
time it's like you're having trouble
breathing there's a ventilator and then
people do experiments this is the value
of experiments say well if you tip this
way or you you breathe through a hole in
the table whatever and there's a better
chance and that gets published gets
disseminated and then you have a new
best practice in that moment and the
public the public saw this happening in
real normally it happens you don't even
see it right because it's a controlled
study on some corner of the world or in
some country you don't even see it until
it's already tested out but you don't
want to hold a vaccine longer than
necessary if you could be saving lives
with it hence the emergency Provisions
that were put into place so the problem
was I think people don't know what
science is or how on why it works and if
you taught that in school you'd say okay
this is a The Mask but we also need to
clean the things because we know viruses
transmit on the surfaces turns out this
virus was less a surface virus and more
of an Airborne virus oh yeah I remember
I had a buddy who was wearing a hazmat
suit to get his instacart deliveries and
he was pressure washing boxes of
Triscuits because at the time that we
know that to be successful against
variants of a virus but it not that one
we didn't know yet yeah but are you
going to say well we don't know yet so
therefore I'm not going to do anything
no you do what has worked in other okay
you do that until we refine it people
were not allowing science to run its
course do you think that during the
pandemic that the uh that the
um
the uh vaccine and the bio company the
pharmaceutical companies that they
hijacked science or hijacked them well
their studies get reviewed by uh panels
of scientists that's what the FDA does
that's the whole point one of the main
points of the FDA is to do this so they
study the efficacy of the of the virus
of the vaccine and they study how
effective is it against children also
things like it can be effective but at
what dose the most there's more than one
moving part here in the studies they did
the studies and they found it was like
95 effective against that variance so
they said let's roll it out no need to
do further experiments on this on the
effectiveness of the vaccine now here's
here's an interesting challenge
if your vaccine is so perfect
that it knocks out this variant
perfectly
it might not be effective against
another variant of that same virus right
oh it could be too perfect okay it could
be too perfect correct
and so though we need search research
this may be going I'm not I'm not on
that Frontier of of a viral serum that's
more sort of a cocktail
of antiviral elements so that whenever
the thing tries to morph or or or mutate
we got you you can't mutate out of this
out of this group of
um and so what they do now with the flu
vaccine is they just they have the
specific
um uh uh uh they have the specific
recipes and they they do cocktail
together uh for the the seasonal flu
virus because they see different fluids
showing up and and they put them
together but I I foresee a day when you
take one antiviral serum it takes cat
takes out all viruses that'd be a fun
day do you think that yeah because a lot
of we had Bobby Kennedy on and he was
talking about like he was really against
Dr fauci in a lot of like yeah he's yeah
he has a book The Truth About Dr fauci
right so he's he's he's an
environmentalist so he was always grew
up like about the environment right yeah
then he's like about the environment
inside of your body he you know I he
believes that a lot of vaccines and
stuff like can cause more damage over
time yeah except when you look at the
people who don't die for having had the
vaccine so there's a a lot of I mean
there's a lot of cherry picking of data
I mean I think he came to this vaccine
argument uh this vaccine world because
he's he sees the abuses of corporate
agreed yeah all right and in the
environment a corporation will do
something regardless of its effective
environment or its effect on people so
he I think that not that he's an expert
on vaccines and virology or anything but
that he sees big corporations he sees
governments like he's a lawyer yeah and
he sees people and he wants to protect
people so that's a noble cause a legacy
of his entire family of course that in
multi-generations so but what happens is
people can get they get onto something
that they think is true
and but the law there's a larger
statistical truth
that negates what you think if you see
three cases because the testimony is
strong because or or someone
coincidentally gets some other thing
after they get a an injection and they
and they they stand up and give a talk
he said oh my gosh this is the this is
what I'm telling you they're looking
into the person's eyes and you feel
their emotions and you see the fire and
that becomes more real to you than a pie
chart yeah
so it's interesting you can get caught
up in that and but do you think that
these days like that because you're from
the science community that like big
Pharma like they have enough money and
power that they could alter because
that's what I feel like a lot of people
that they could alter the data or cherry
pick it enough and present it to humans
in a way that would just support what
they want well so so what that's what I
think in the end a lot of people
probably that's the thing that I think
people think
that big Pharma
hijacked a lot of the information or
adjusted it to make people believe and
think okay except we have people dying
in the hospital who are not vaccinated
and people alive who were right so you
can keep talking okay you can keep
saying whatever you want
but we have evidence
that conflicts with your conspiratorial
views right and evidence matters in the
end and so you know could they have
faked could they have put their entire
100-year reput Pfizer or whatever how
old they are but I think it's around
there 100 Year reputation
on the line
by faking data
so that we would all think their vaccine
will keep us out of the hospital
just to sell it
we would know within weeks if not days
if that was all a lie yeah
we would know
because there would be as many people in
the hospital who've been dying who've
been vaccinated who were not and those
are two samples you want to compare with
each other yeah and when you compare
that no that it's effective it's
effective now what what what took people
by what surprise people is yeah you
vaccine vaccinate me against the measles
I'm not getting the measles you can
breathe on me I'm not getting the
measles all right so how why do people
still get coveted after they got
vaccinated against covid yeah
they got a lighter case of covet then
they would have otherwise gotten ah okay
you surely know people who got coveted
who were vaccinated there was a you know
five-day vacation at home okay use a box
of tissues and you're back a few days
later were they on ventilators and were
they even admitted to a hospital no no
when people get it now I'm like I almost
think they're [ __ ]
you know people are like I got covered
like [ __ ] get in here yeah do your
work dude
I'll take it
um do you worry about the like so
science is information right and
objective information are things that
can't change if it's been verified by
multiple experiments right and there's a
result that comes out of it that's not
tomorrow going to be different from
today do you worry about the way that we
share information now because that's
almost scarier that's
you know just like news channels and
outlets and clips the way we see things
it's adjusting people's the way we think
all the time it's taking over the value
of the information that's insightful and
perceptive and correct that they're not
only controlling the information you
receive they're shaping how you receive
it
which has an effect on how you then
behave and act on that information
so as a scientist we're trained not only
successfully we're trained to detach
from the emotions of a testimony
we're trained to
be skeptical of a claim that's made
that's opposite other claims that have
been made before
if someone says we've seen the YouTubers
who's the dude hanging on his arm
uh uh no no no no the guy who wants you
to do his diet uh his muscle grow he
wants you to grow muscles he's a muscle
Sylvester Stallone no no he's just some
guy he's just some guy okay like a
fitness expert okay but he's got
something he's selling you and he's
saying you know the best way to get
ripped muscles it's not by going to the
gym every day it's by doing my thing oh
okay so it's we respond to that once
again it's the easy way out we respond
to a testimony that's saying everybody
else is wrong but this is right
as a scientist we are trained to be
skeptical of that claim
the person that says all these
scientists and all they're all wrong and
they're all in conspiracy but I'm
correct listen to me we're trained to be
and then not to just be skeptical and go
on with life I'm gonna find out if what
you're saying is true why is conspiracy
because conspiracies uh and the idea of
conspiracy theories have grown more in
the past 10 years I think so I think so
it seems like sadly but yes do you wait
what do you attribute that to the urge
to be comfortable in your own belief
system we started the conversation that
way yeah you were saying this is what I
am and if someone's poking at the sides
I don't want it I don't want to know
about it so now you create a world view
you create an understanding of how
things are
either because someone convinced you or
you convinced yourself okay
now there's a gap
or there's some information that
conflicts with it
so you're going to say if you cherish
this world view that information that
conflicts with it was falsified
or that was wrong they don't know what
they're doing or if there's a gap in the
information you'll say someone's hiding
and that so you say by saying someone
hiding it that Bridges you from one bit
of information to another and you can
maintain your world view um
as a scientist it is our duty
to disturb our worldview every day the
headline that says scientists have to go
back to the drawing board because their
cherished theories might be put in
Jeopardy this is [ __ ]
we're at the drawing board every single
day of Our Lives that's what we do is
what we live for a new discovery who is
this we're not in our office with our
feet up on the desk masters of all the
knowledge of the universe that's not us
who is uh who tests who is the final
say-so of something from science that it
can go into society
well in my field there's none of that
because we the patient doesn't die okay
I can be spectacularly wrong about how a
galaxy is rotating and uh there's no
there's no product that's going to be
made based on it right so so as you as
what you do gets closer and closer to
the condition to The Human Condition
then you need sort of regulations and
careful scrutiny that's why the FDA
exists and there's no counterpart to the
FDA for astrophysics
can the FDA be compromised or not uh in
principle I think anything can be
compromised but what you so what it
comes down to is
you would say the FDA is saying this
does any other agency
say something completely different
I'm not talking about a YouTube page A
Little Agency if this isn't complete
then then let's take a closer look it's
a reason to look closer not a reason to
reject or accept that's all and uh might
they give oh so here's one I got one
uh the food pyramid
oh yeah I remember that this is a
completely red interesting
I I'm even gonna say honest
uh
should I say let me not use the word
it's an interesting
sequence of events okay here it is okay
there's a study in Europe
tens of thousands of people it's a diet
study okay okay and they find out
that
uh the Mediterranean diet is healthier
for you low in saturated fats low butter
not so much meat uh grains
are been there so beans and and wheat
and this sort of thing and so and
saturated fats that's bad for you it'll
reduce your so this study came out here
we are okay this study came out and it
was
it took the World by storm because it
was so many people and European Europe
is is westernized right and we all live
a western life so This was oh my gosh
we all got to do this so drop the
saturated fats drop the cholesterol drop
all this stuff that'll kill you fast and
eat the Breads and things and that okay
that's what contributed to
uh to impart the the the just the die
the a carb diet okay and when we did
that everybody started getting fat
um everybody started getting fat you
know what happens something else happens
right there's a other side of it there's
another carb in your diet puts your
metabolism on a roller coaster
and you end up with food cravings
that you didn't previously have because
you got your calories from sources other
than carbohydrates so there was a
secondary effect that was not folded in
but more important that European study
of have forgot how many countries
was missing
France
how do you have a European study that
doesn't have France in it I don't know
people don't like them okay
I mean that was no other explanation
we hate the French maybe they didn't
call them maybe they didn't answer when
you called okay you have a study but
that is yeah that's the cholesterol well
not just you have to have everybody
which is true
you have a study telling people that
cholesterol is bad for you
and you're missing a country
that is
steeped in animal fat
the foreground the butter the croissant
the duck fat all of this ducks are
[ __ ] awesome do you know that the
life expectancy in France
is like 30 six months no it's like six
months shorter than Italy which has the
Mediterranean France has also got to
Mediterranean thing but their diet you
don't think it was the Mediterranean
diet so they had no it's not
significantly less life expected than
other countries that didn't eat any of
that and that was not in the study put
it in so the study had a built-in bias
that people were not thinking of at the
time the study was so this is the bias
you have to watch out for yeah here we
are doing experiment believing something
that's not true
and that's why lately they say put in
some cholesterol back in your diet
it's and and and because we're learning
that
what we thought was true out of that
from that one study that's the point
one study doesn't make the truth you
need other study that test it and
re-verify it
yeah because I saw I was watching uh
well I was just watching that show dope
sick and it was about like the opioid
crisis or whatever yeah yeah it was
crazy yeah yeah it's crazy sometimes
that why do we let bad things
into our society that seems so bad you
know
um it would seem like sometimes we would
be able to well we have addiction
problems I mean that's a problem yeah
that's a good point yeah right if we
didn't have addiction problems then you
need none of that right right yeah let
me get high today and then I'm fine
tomorrow right I'm not you know so
that's a susceptibility we have in our
physiology so but you can be a gambling
addicted and the many addictions oh yeah
we got a lot of addicts listening to
this okay
the addictions are are that weakness and
when you have other people that exploit
that weakness yeah like the casinos and
the drug dealers anything yeah anything
yeah anything someone's there to make
money offer your inability to stop what
you're doing yeah that's what I worry
about like even with the drug dealers at
like big levels it's like are we is our
FDA compromisable sometimes I worry you
know or if we've gotten to that point as
a country where everything's com like
we're just it's more well if you if you
lose all confidence in the agencies and
the entire system
um
then where are you going to put your
confidence is it the YouTube channel you
were looking at is it the
yeah is it the guy on the YouTube
channel say the FDA is wrong about
everything right I'm right buy what I'm
selling you right where so it's a good
question I think but that's what I think
you see a I don't know if you see a lot
of that happening but I think there's
people who don't know where to put their
confidence anymore I feel like we used
to all know where to put our confidence
does that make any sense
um yes but I'm saying there are people
who are sowing doubt in places where
there's no need to do so uh people who
are indicting the entire scientific
Community oh by the way while they're
still using their smartphone okay I I
sent out a tweet should I have left it
in my forbidden file I don't know it was
a letter it was like deer flat earthers
anti-vaxxers uh homeopath homeopaths and
on a whole list of like pseudoscience
okay dear
you
you found each other
and communicate with one another
using a device
that
that using a sophisticated device that
uses Frontier Advanced discoveries in
engineering science technology and math
just thought I'd alert you of this fact
sign your your smartphone okay this is
the letter your smartphone should be
telling you every day yeah it's true I
don't trust science science is this oh
wait what's the best way to root the
round of traffic to get to Grandma's
house which is using GPS satellites and
what do you think we do as scientists
and by the way people think that
scientists are somehow conspiring have
you ever been to a scientific conference
we're arguing all the time yeah we don't
agree it's a great point no it's just I
that's a great point
it's really you're living twice as long
as your great-grandparents because of
science yeah oh I don't trust science
science
it's interesting right I yeah I don't
know I wonder where all this dis where
the distrust started to really come from
I feel like
20 years ago it wasn't here well I think
maybe it was there was some distrust
that began uh with Nixon and Watergate
oh yeah where can we trust our
government and institutions we knew they
were corrupt politicians every now and
then but the system for it to be
embedded and the and the the the papers
the Pentagon papers this is stuff going
that was released out of the Vietnam War
smuggled out the New York Times reported
on it you learned the the shaky stuff
Shady stuff we're doing are we the noble
Freedom Fighters to the world or are we
sleazy corporate so I think it began
then so it means yes skepticism is fine
but skepticism is not the same thing as
everything you tell me is wrong right
sister says let me double check that
yeah that's a that's a really really
great thing to say man and that's a
great thing to remember and I think it's
interesting because that's what it's
some of your book a lot of your book is
interesting things to think about
different ways to think about them
um and like I said if you're going to
read it at all
read it before Thanksgiving dinner
and you just calmly say well have you
thought of this thought of this you'll
be the calmest arguer there ever was
that's what I will say there's a lot of
great have you thought of this and it's
it was some parts were like I don't know
if I want to think about that but it's
nice my one last question for you what
do you got sometimes I look up at the
sky right and I'll look up and I feel
like especially if there's stars out
there I'll feel like
uh
uh it's kind of like like something's
looking back at me does that make any
sense to you at all
I I once tweeted something like that I
said sometimes I wonder
as i gaze into the night sky
whether the Stars themselves are gazing
back at me oh damn I didn't realize I
sounded so damn bi about it
and that's when people said are you high
and you'll put down the joint are you
this is this is a reliable influx of
people who are certainly look up I think
there's a like a thing I don't know what
it is bro I don't think it's gay or
anything I think it'll just feel like
the space is looking back at me
well
maybe I'm gay for space bro well so
I we're not likely the only life forms
in the universe
there's probably very many some vastly
more intelligent than we are
here here we're sitting here looking up
into the night sky countless thousands
of stars with binoculars it rises into
the millions of stars with telescopes it
rises into the billions oh God there is
surely civilizations there
looking up at their night sky
and they see our star
the Sun as part of some constellation
that they identify in their night sky
and there's a Theo Von there looking up
asking is anyone up there looking down
at me
and we get to say yes we have your
counterparts
we gotta feel fun in this galaxy too no
no I'm just saying uh it's fun to think
about we being in the night sky of some
children's diagram as seen by another
place in the galaxy
you got to answer the question what do
you tell me about the individuals
whatever would you say oh yeah yeah okay
I'll take you out with that
do you know how precious life is most
people don't I didn't know I think
because look at the risks we take oh let
me jump out of an airplane you know and
maybe the shoot will open
all right that's a whole kind of person
we got out there just look at YouTube
videos oh yeah all right with the GoPro
yeah exactly exactly all right
there's been about a hundred billion
people who have ever lived
wow really yes and there's only eight
billion now no about 100 billion if you
add it up over all time damn all right
so now
do you know how many people can exist
you take a look at the genes find out
how many combinations of genes can make
an authentic human being
and you do that you can do the math on
this and it is stupendously larger
number
than the 100 billion
it it is
I I I've given number in here but that
even that's a low estimate that could
have existed over time or that could
exist total
same difference okay okay so I give a
low end number of a million trillion
trillion
total possible numbers of plausible
human beings that could exist
what it means is
you are alive
against stupendous odds
you are breathing air observing sunsets
gazing into the night sky
most people who could exist
will never experience that wow
in fact
as Richard Dawkins has said brilliantly
you get to die
and he said I don't want to die I'm die
most people who could exist
will never even be born
and you're going to complain about the
life you have
yes not all lives are equally I get that
yes and you could get the wrong hand
dealt to you either birth defects or or
your family
whatever it is oh my God that is your
whatever it is
that's what you've got
yeah use it
develop it
do all you can within your power and the
power of others who love you
to to maximize
what you can be what you can think what
you you can learn how you can love all
of this your gift it's the gift because
as you most people most people that
could exist mathematically will never
exist wow
so right there you are a you you are a
special
a living entity as there ever was amen
so that so in the end of this chapter
and and and what I do as an Epitaph
there's a quote from an educator
Horseman
uh you might have heard the name he was
200 years ago brilliant guy head of
universities he gave a commencement
speech
and he said I beseech you love that word
nobody uses it anymore yeah you get I
mean you feel girls hang up immediately
oh is that right is that right I I
haven't tested it I don't know I'll try
to bring it back and maybe it'll stay on
with you I beseech you yeah if you say I
beseech you to go on a date with me
right that's that's the end of that call
right there good day
um I beseech you to treasure up in your
hearts
these my parting words
be ashamed to die
until you've scored some victory for
Humanity
and if you've got one time on Earth
there it is
there it is uh Neil deGrasse Tyson thank
you so much for your time man it really
uh Delight to meet you of course I know
your work and it's it's as it says
authentically honest
it's you know
it's unpretentious you're just feeling
it out there on stage and people people
people know you're feeling it and they
feel it too and I think it's some it's
some potent humor which which gives you
some power
that you know you have power but it's
even more power than that because you
can bring people with you I'm starting
to realize that more you know I want to
be able to be as creative as I can in
work and also I want to be able to
question things and think about stuff as
much as I can so I'm really grateful for
this conversation right now in my life
and to stay relevant as a comedian you
got to stay on that Frontier right you
can't relax for a minute oh man plus a
joke you told last week you can't tell
next week yeah we're scientists well
I'll tell a few but but you'll hear the
groan the audience reaction evolves
right well part of the groan is deep
inside of myself because it knows it's
not I'm not maximizing my potential yeah
okay so yeah
um but thank you so much for your time
man uh dude thanks for having me yeah
you're uh you're a value to humanity and
we appreciate you thank you
now I'm just floating on the breeze and
I feel I'm falling like these leaves I
must be
Cornerstone
I'll share this piece of my life and I
can feel it in my bones
it's gonna take